MUCH AND WELCOME TO OUR WEEKLY
SCHEDULE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
THE CHAIR NOTICES THE PRESENCE
OF A FELLOW REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER. BUT WE ARE ABSENCE OF A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THERE.
HAS BEEN A REQUEST.
FOR AN AUTHOR TO ADHERE A FEW
BILLS OUT OF ORDER IT DUE TO
PRIOR OBLIGATIONS
AS WELL AS A WRITTEN REQUEST FOR
AN ADDITIONAL AUTHOR DUE TO. A
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS OF
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SO A WITH
THAT SAID OUT WE WILL NOW BEGIN
WITH.
A FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AND
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE FOLLOWED BY ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN SO AGAIN FILE AND OVER
THREE KALRA AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN. OF FOLLOWED BY FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
EIGHTY FOUR. THEN NINE FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN WHICH IS A B.
THIRTY ONE TEN MULLIN AND THEY
WILL GO BACK IN THE REGULAR
ORDER.
SO HAVING SAID THAT. IF A
MISTER KALRA AND CAN JOIN US
HERE AT THE PODIUM I WILL BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
WHICH IS AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN.
AS A MEMBER KALRA PLEASE
PRESENT WHATEVER READY AND FOUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT UP TO THREE
MINUTES AND WITNESSES OPPOSITION
UP TO THREE MINUTES.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR ACCOMMODATING.
MY REQUESTS AND THANK YOU.
TIM THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS. OF
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN TODAY.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY WOULD ALLOW
VETERINARIANS TO DISCUSS THE USE
OF CANNABIS WITHOUT FEAR OF
LOSING THEIR LICENSE. AND
ENABLES CANNABIS FOR MEDICINAL
ANIMAL USE TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
CONSUMERS AND REGULATED
DISPENSARIES.
TODAY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS TO CANNABIS
CONSUMERS ALREADY HAD THE
ABILITY TO GET THEIR PETS
CANNABIS WITHOUT VETERINARIAN
DISCUSSION.
CONTRA CONTRA WIDELY HELD
KNOWLEDGE.
VETERINARIANS DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE THE SAME PROTECTIONS THAT
POSITIONS ARE GIVEN.
SO IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
VETERINARIANS WAS BE SUBJECT TO
DISCIPLINE. OR PROSECUTION IF
THIRD TO DISCUSS THE USE OF
MEDICINAL CANNABIS ON ANIMAL
WITHIN THE VETERINARIAN CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP.
IT IS CRITICAL FOR THE
PROTECTION OF OUR BELOVED PETS
THAT VETERINARIAN'S BE ALLOWED
TO DISCUSS THE SAFE USE AND
MEDICINAL VALUE OF CANADA'S
PRODUCTS. ALREADY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
EVEN THOUGH OF THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD HAS NO POSITION ON
THE BILL A WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING.
TO WORK WITH THEM AS A BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
THIS FIRST STEP OF ALLOWING FOR
DISCUSSION IS AN IMPORTANT ONE
AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM SUPPORT
WITNESSES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LICENSED.
VETERINARIANS.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN ALSO
REQUIRES THE BOARD TO ESTABLISH
GUIDELINES FOR LICENSE
VETERINARIANS THAT CAN BE THE
BASIS FOR DISCUSSIONS ON THE USE
OF CANNABIS ON AN ANIMAL
PATIENT.
SOME ARE GUIDELINES FOR
POSITIONS WERE RECOMMENDING
CANNABIS WERE DEVELOPED BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
LASTLY TO ENSURE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS WERE MEDICINAL USE ON
ANIMALS CAN BE AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS IN A REGULATED MARKET.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN AS THESE
PRODUCTS TO THE DEFINITION UNDER
THE MEDICINAL ADULT USE CANNABIS
REGULATION AND SAFETY ACT.
THIS WILL ENABLE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO COME TO MARKET THAT
ARE SAFE FOR PET USE RATHER THAN
PET OWNERS USING CAMERAS
PRODUCTS DESIGNED. FOR HUMAN USE
ON THEIR PETS
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
AND WE HAVE WELL IF WE COULD
MISTER CHAIR ONE WITNESS A CURE
TODAY DR CABIN LAZAR CHEF. OF
THE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS CRISTINA CARL HERE
FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OF THE MORNING WHO'S
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE I'M DUCK
KEVIN LAZAR CHEF ON PRESIDENT
THAT CALIFORNIA BETTER MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THIS YEAR.
MOST OF THE VETERINARIAN OUR
SMALL PRACTICE YOU NEED TO
MADERA COUNTY NEAR YOSEMITE.
THIS EVENING MAYES PLEASED TO
BE ABLE SUPPORT A. B. TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMAN KALRA.
IT'S TRULY A SIGN OF THE TIMES
THAT EARNINGS WILL TELL YOU THAT
THEIR CLIENTS ARE COMING IN.
TO THEIR OFFICES WEEKLY WITH
STORIES ABOUT IT CANNABIS USE IN
THEIR PETS.
EITHER DOGS ACCIDENTALLY
CONSUMED A POT EDIBLE.
AND IS VERY SICK OR THE CLIENT
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT CBD OIL FOR
THEIR PETS ARTHRITIC HIP.
IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE ATTORNEY FOR THE VERY
MEDICAL BOARD.
THE PINE THAT THE IN MEMORANDUM
THAT CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
THAT EARNINGS TO EVEN HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT CANNABIS.
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS.
OF OUR ANIMAL PATIENTS.
BRINKLEY THINK THIS IS THE
APPLICATION OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS.
TO NOT HAVE THESE OPEN AND
HONEST DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR
CLIENTS.
IT'S PRETTY FRIGHTENING WHEN THE
CLIENTS NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF
INFORMATION. IS THE INTERNET.
OR THEIR LOCAL BUT TENDER THE
CANNABIS DISPENSARY. THESE
PEOPLE HAVE NO BETTER MADE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS WHY ASSEMBLY COLLARS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT TO US.
AB TWENTY TO FIFTEEN ALLOW THEIR
NAMES TO HAVE A CLINICAL
DISCUSSION.
WITH OUR PETS OWNERS WITHOUT
HAVING TO.
FEAR BEING SANCTIONED BY AFARIA
MEDICAL BOARD.
EVEN THE VM. BE OPINION. SUGGEST
THAT LEGISLATOR LEGISLATIVE
REMEDIES THE ONLY WAY TO ADDRESS
THIS CURRENT VOIDING LAW.
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMAN KALRA
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN THIS
ARENA.
WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CRISTINA
DO CARRO WITH THE CDMA JUST HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE KALRA MICROPHONE NAME
INFLATION FOR THE RECORD IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO.
THANK YOU ON MEXICO US WITH CASE
THREE CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF
THAT CBD.
IF THE PRODUCERS OF A
VETERINARIAN FORMULATE CBT
PRODUCTS IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I'M DOCTOR CHAU WATERHOUSE
PRESIDENT THE BETTER MEDICAL
BOARD DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
TOPIC FORWARD.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THIS ISSUE OF
MARIJUANA USE IN ANIMALS.
GOOD MORNING AMY JENKINS OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
MARVIN BEEN AND I WITH THE
UNITED CAMAS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IS POOR THE BILL AYE
WE REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
DISPENSARIES WE OFFER PRODUCTS
FOR ANIMALS. AND WE DO NEED THE
GUY AND SUCH THINGS FROM BEING
IN THE BILL FOR.
BRENT MARTEN ON BEHALF OF CMG
CLEAVE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
OUR DEAL BERENGER WITH
CALIFORNIA NORMAL NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR REFORM OF
MARIJUANA LAWS. A CO SPONSOR OF
PROPOSITION TWO FIFTEEN WE HEAR
A LOT ABOUT.
CANNABIS FOR PATCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TINO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THEM MICROPHONE.
CARILLO GET AND TOTAL OPPOSITION
FOR PETS.
PETS ARE SICK FROM EVEN USE IN
IT WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT'S GOING
ON.
SO IT'S UNFAIR THAT'S ANIMAL
ABUSE.
THANK THAT YOU VERY MUCH CLICKS
INDIVIDUAL PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING PAUL HAS VERY
MENDOCINO COUNTY.
FOR MANY YEARS YOU KNOW MY
PARTNER AND I HAVE BEEN
ACTIVISTS ATTEMPTING TO.
EDUCATE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE.
OR FOR AND TO HELP SHAPE THE
RESTRICTIVE AND SOMETIMES
ONEROUS AND SEEMINGLY PUNITIVE.
OF REGULATIONS AND LAWS
CONCERNING MEDICAL CANNABIS.
IT FEELS STRANGE TO BE HERE TO
VOICE OPPOSITION TO A BILL THAT
AT THE HEART OF THE MATTER.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT IT HAS NO
LEGS ARMS OR HEAD.
PROP SIXTY FOUR ALLOWS ACCESS TO
ANYONE OVER TWENTY ONE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A TOXIC DOES NO
MATTER HOW WELL INTENTIONED.
BEING GIVEN TO A PET THE NAME A
MEDICAL CANNABIS IS EXTREMELY
HIGH.
PET OWNERS AT LEAST DESERVE THE
THE OPTION OF GETTING INFORMED
RECOMMENDATION.
NOT JUST DISCUSSION.
FROM A TRAINED PROFESSIONAL
REGARDING THE DOSAGE AND HOUSE
TO SAFELY ADMINISTER THE MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
HEADER MIS INFORMATION FROM THE
INTERNET OR ADVICE FROM A REAL
RETAIL SALES PERSON IS SIMPLY
INADEQUATE.
AND WHEN A FAMILY MEMBERS HEALTH
AND WELL BEING IS AT STAKE.
WHILE THE COURSES ARE AFFECTED
AYE WISPY TO CONTINUING
EDUCATION.
WHAT COURSES ARE BE ARE? OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION IS A
REQUIREMENT.
AS IT IS WITH MEDICAL DOCTORS
IN ORDER TO KEEP THEIR LICENSE
ACTIVE.
IF A VETERINARIAN CHOOSES TO
INCORPORATE THE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS INTO THEIR PRACTICE IT
ONLY MAKES SENSE THAT THEY
SHOULD KNOW WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND WHAT THEY'RE
RECOMMENDING.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN CURRENTLY
ALLOWS FOR DISCUSSION WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO RECOMMEND. THE
SIMPLY JUST HAD IT SAYS THE
VETERINARIANS HAVE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
ALLOWING CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO BE
MANUFACTURED AND SOLD FOR
ANIMALS IT BOLSTERS THE MARKET
NO DOUBT. BUT THERE'S NO SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS OF FOR THE ANIMALS.
THE MEDICAL ONLY RETAIL OUTLETS
IS GREAT.
BUT WHAT IF THE CLIENT.
THE CAREGIVER FOR THE PET.
DOES NOT HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
FROM THEIR FAMILY MET FAMILY
DOCTOR.
THE EASY ANSWER IS TO ALLOW THAT
PRODUCTS IN RECREATIONAL OUTLETS
THERE IS NO RECREATIONAL USE FOR
ANIMALS.
THIS WOULD MAKE THE PROBLEM
WORSE.
WHAT WOULD BE UNETHICAL TO SHARE
THE CLIENT INFORMATION VETERANS
ARE NOT BOUND BY HIPAA PRIVACY
LAWS FOR THEIR PATIENTS?
WHAT BETTER WAY TO COLLECT DATA
FOR A BODY OF EVIDENCE TO DRIVE
RESEARCH FOR THE TRIALS THERE
ARE ALWAYS A I ASK FOR AND
DESPERATELY NEEDED?
THERE'S A LOT OF LANGUAGE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IN THIS BILL SOME
WOULD SAY IT'S A GOOD START WE
WOULD SAY LET'S GET IT RIGHT AND
THEN BUILD ON THAT LEADER.
.
WE WOULD SUPPORT THIS BILL OF
LANGUAGE AT A MINIMUM WORK TO
INCLUDE A VETERINARY
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH CONTINUING
PROVIDED THEY'VE.
OF FINISHED THEIR CONTINUING
EDUCATION COMPLETED CONTINUING
EDUCATION COURSE OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE.
ALEX CANNABIS MEDICINE.
NUMBER TWO REQUIRE VETERAN
VETERINARY RECOMMENDATION TO HER
MIND THAT IRAQ HAVE THIS HOT AT
LEAST.
THIS WOULD ENSURE SAFETY FOR THE
ANIMAL FURTHER THE PROFESSION
FURTHER RESEARCH AND ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPMENT RESPONSIBLE DO
PRODUCT FOR MEDICINE. LET'S
START TREATING MEDICAL CANNABIS
AS MEDICINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WOODS IS UNDER ME
TO KNOW THAT OUR THREE MINUTES
ARE UP.
GOOD MORNING SUSAN TIBBON FORMER
CURRICULUM WRITER AN INSTRUCTOR
SAN FRANCISCO SPCA CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES.
WE'RE REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
PET OWNERS AND HUNDREDS OF
VETERINARIANS WHO HAVE SIGNED
PETITIONS URGING MORE INCLUSIVE
LANGUAGE FOR THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BILL.
MEDICINE IS MEDICINE IT'S
INFORMED BY PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATION.
VETERINARIANS RECOMMENDATION
SAME IS AN MD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO.
MAY I FINISH DE YOU THAT WE ARE
THREE MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION IS
UP SO YOU YOU MADE YOUR ALSO
THEIR THREE MINUTES OPPOSITION
TOTAL YES CORRECT YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOW WHAT CONDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME I SOME OF A CAR AS YOU KNOW
WE ARE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
NOW BUT IF YOU WISH TO CLOSE AT
ADDRESSING THE OTHER ADDITIONAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON THIS SHOW
I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF OF WORKING SO CLOSELY
WITH OUR STAFF.
IN ORDER TO. NOT JUST SEE THIS
THROUGH BUT OFFER AMENDMENTS
THAT WE DO GRATEFULLY ACCEPT.
AND THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE AND SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I HOPE THAT.
THAT THAT THE MEMBERS ABOUT AYE
ALLEN TO GET THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUMMER KALRA
WILL TAKE A VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
AND IF YOU WISH TO MOVE ON AT TO
COMPLETE
A FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY
FOUR.
SPECTER COURT REPORTERS.
AND AGAIN.
.
THROUGH UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND UP
TO THREE MINUTES FOR WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST ONCE AGAIN.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE ENTITIES
PROVIDING PURPORTING SERVICES TO
REGISTER WITH THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD AS COURT
REPORTING PROVIDERS. IN ORDER TO
ACQUIRE COMPLAINTS OF THE SAME
LAWS AND REGULATIONS THAT
DICTATE FAIR AND NEUTRAL COURT
REPORTING.
COR REPORTING IS INTEGRAL A
COMPONENT OF OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
IS THE ROLE IT IS THE ROLE OF
THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD
PROTECTS INTEGRITY BY MAKING
SURE ALL ENTITIES ARE PLAYING BY
THE SAME RULES.
THIS ENSURES CONSUMERS ARE
PROTECTED FROM ACTIONS THEY GIVE
ONE SIDE AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE OR
PRACTICES THAT COMPROMISE THE
NEUTRAL CARE OF THE COURT
REPORTER'S TRANSCRIPT.
THERE HAVE BEEN REPORTED ABUSES
FROM OUT OF SE CORPORATIONS THE
PROVIDE COURT REPORTING FOR
DEPOSITIONS.
THESE ENTITIES USE LICENSE COURT
REPORTERS BUT IN THE COURSE OF
THEIR BUSINESS HAVE DIRECT
HANDLING OF THE TRANSCRIPT IN A
MANNER THAT BREAKS COURT
REPORTING LAWS REGULATIONS.
ONE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
VIOLATIONS INVOLVES TRANSCRIPT
DELIVERY. DURING WHICH THE FIRM
WILL PROVIDE THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE CLIENT BEFORE OPPOSING
COUNSEL.
GIVING A SIGNIFICANT LITIGATION
ADVANTAGE A TO THEIR CLIENT
CONTRARY TO EXISTING LAW.
AS SOMEONE THE PRACTICE OF
RELIGION YEARS DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND RELIED HEAVILY ON
NOT JUST THE WORLD COURT
REPORTERS BUT THE TRANSCRIPTS I
CAN TELL YOU THAT. ANY KIND OF
INCONSISTENCY ABOVE A IN THE
HANDLING OF TRANSCRIPTS.
POSES A GRAVE RISK OF THE TWO
EQUITY IN THE COURT SYSTEM.
WITHOUT HOLDING ALL ENTITIES THE
SAME LAWS REGULATION A CREATES
INEQUITIES IN THE PROVISION OF
COURT REPORTING SERVICES. AND
UNDERMINE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR RESPONSE
BY THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD AND
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION. AND
THE DEPTH OF THE DEPOSITION
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION.
AB. AND.
LOOKING TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES BONVENTRE CHAIR THE
COURT REPORTERS BOARD AS WELL AS
JIM GROSS ON BEHALF THE
DEPOSITIONS.
I REPORTERS ASSOCIATION US ONE
OF AND BY SAYING I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US SINCE
LAST YEAR ON THIS UP PARTICULAR
ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT UP TO THREE
MINUTES IT'S FOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
MY NAME IS YVONNE FENNER I'M THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD ON I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR BOARD CHAIR
READING UNEXPECTED EMERGE
EMERGENCY THIS MORNING SO. I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I'M THIS
ARTICULATE BUT THESE ARE HER
REMARKS
BOB SHE WANTED ME TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE BRINGING
FORWARD TO YOU AN UNCOMPLICATED
WELL VETTED FISCALLY SMART
SOLUTION IN AB TWENTY EIGHTY
FOUR THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL
CONSUMERS OF COURT REPORTING
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
PROTECTED. WHETHER THE SECURE
THOSE SERVICES THROUGH A
LICENSEE OWNED FIRM ANON
LICENSEE OWNED FIRM. AND IN
STATE CORPORATION OR AN OUT OF
STATE CORPORATION NO ONE SHOULD
BE ABOVE THE LAW. WHY WE ARE
HERE BECAUSE THAT COURT
REPORTERS MISSION IS TO SERVE
AND PROTECT THE COURTROOM
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS? AND IT'S
BEEN NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
GROWING DISREGARD FOR EXISTING
LAWS BY OUT OF STATE NON
LICENSEE ON FIRMS OFFERING COURT
REPORTING SERVICES. COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES INCORPORATED.
UNLIKE OTHER INDUSTRY MEMBERS
WHO ARE FOLLOWING COURT
REPORTING LAWS AND ETHICS A
COLLECTION OF THESE OUT OF STATE
FIRMS HAVE TRIED TO REWRITE
EXISTING LAWS BY SAYING WE ARE
SOMEHOW EXEMPT.
SO THE BOARD BOARD IS WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND AB TWENTY
EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES A CLEAR
PATHWAY FOR THESE OUT OF STATE
CORPORATIONS TO OFFER COURT
REPORTING SERVICES WHY BEING
WHILE BEING HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS.
SO WE WELCOME COMPETITION TO THE
STATE COMPETITION IS GOOD FOR
THE CONSUMER.
BUT WE DON REALLY BELIEVE
EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE HELD TO THE
SAME STANDARD AND WE ASKFOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
JIM GROWS UP AFTER THE
DEPOSITION REPORTERS ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE WORKED ON THIS BILL FOR
THE LAST. THREE YEARS AND I
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL ALLOW FOR
COMPETITION DESPITE WHAT SOME OF
THE OPPONENTS HAVE SAID IN THE
PAST. WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HE'S NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ AND WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTER SOCIAIS AND.
STRONG SUPPORT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE. ALONG
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AND ALLIES
AND.
THE AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
DISASTERS PART.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT FEEL FREE TO
COMMIT TO THAT MICROPHONE SEEM
NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. A WE NOW WELCOME
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION A PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
TASK.
YOU'LL HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MIKE
FOLLOWED ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF DEPOSITION NATIONAL
DEPOSITION FIRMS. INCLUDING
VARITEK'S US LEGAL.
AND ESQUIRE.
THIS BILL IS WELL KNOWN TO THE
COMMITTEE AND IT AND STAFF AND
MEMBERS OF THE IDENTICAL BILL
WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR.
A IN SEPTEMBER OF WHO ARGUED.
THAT A THAT THE LEGISLATURE
OUGHT TO WAIT UNTIL PENDING
LITIGATION WAS RESOLVED.
WHICH RELATES DIRECTLY TO THE
QUESTIONS INVOLVED IN THE BILL.
.
THE GOVERNOR APPARENTLY ALTHOUGH
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T SPEAK FOR
HIM.
A WAS EXAMINING THE NEED FOR THE
BILL.
THIS LEGISLATURE AND A LONG
HISTORY OF NOT ACTING IN THE
FACE OF PENDING LITIGATION.
AND THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTIONS
IN THE SO CALLED MOOSE DECISION.
BEAR DIRECTLY ON THE ISSUES
INVOLVED IN THIS BILL.
SO WE WOULD ASK THAT THE BILL BE
HELD PENDING THE RESOLUTION OF
THE MOOSE CASE.
SECONDLY.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE NEED
FOR THE BILL HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED.
WE'VE WAITED WEEK LISTEN TO
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OF PROBLEMS
WE'VE NOT BEEN GIVEN THE.
A WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS IN
SEARCH OF A IS.
GOING AFTER A NONEXISTENT
PROBLEM. THERE IS PROBLEMS IN
COURT REPORTING AND WE SHOULD BE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT AND I CAN NAME
TO WRITE OFF THE TOP.
FIRST COURT REPORTERS ARE NOT
BEING PROVIDED IN CIVIL
LITIGATION IN THE COURTS.
FAMILY LAW LITIGANTS ARE DOING
WITHOUT COURT REPORTERS AND THE
NEED THEM AND THE LEGISLATURE
OUGHT TO ADDRESS THAT.
SECOND BUT THERE'S APPARENTLY A
GROWING SHORTAGE OF COURT
REPORTERS AND YOU MIGHT TAKE A
LOOK AT THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
THE LICENSING OF COURT
REPORTERS.
SO WE COULD HAVE MORE. SO THERE
ARE ISSUES WITH COURT REPORTING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
ADDRESS
THIS ISN'T ONE OF THEM.
THE BILL WAS VETOED AND THAT
HAS PENDING LITIGATION WE WOULD
ASK THAT THE BILL BE HELD.
UNTIL AND UNLESS THE MOOSE
DECISION IS RELEASED AND WE KNOW
WHAT THE COURT THINKS
ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
WITH THAT WE WOULD ASK FOR NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WHAT IS THIS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL VOTE
YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AGAIN
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF OF HOPE
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL.
AND AS INDICATED.
WE WE HAVE BEEN INCOMES IS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT JUST REGARDLESS WHAT THE
OUTCOME IS. IN THE PENDING
LITIGATION THAT THE REST OF THE
LEGISLATION NEEDED AND THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE CONTINUED
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE LAST YEAR IN
SOLID APPRECIATE UP AND PLUGGED
UP AN AYE VOTE FROM THE MEMBERS
I THINK IF THE RECOMMENDATION
WAS A CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUMMER KALRA
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE ACTING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE AND WILL TAKE UP
THE BILL WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ONTO ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
WHICH IS A B. THIRTY ONE TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
SOME AMONG THEM PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY AND AGAIN UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND UP TO THREE MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND AGAIN JUST A CLARIFICATION
FOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT THIS IS FOR TESTIMONY ONLY
AND NO VOTE WILL BE HELD TODAY.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE TENT TO
UP SIMPLY DISCUSSED THE MERITS
OF THE BILL JUST A PRESENTATION
OUT TODAY.
AT THIS TIME I AM WORKING TO
DRAFT AMENDMENTS TO BETTER
DEFINE THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS IT IS MY HOPE
TO TAKE UP THE BILL FOR A VOTE
NEXT WEEK.
IN THE MEANTIME I WOULD LIKE TO
WALK THE COMMITTEE THROUGH MY
INTENT. ON A. B. THIRTY ONE TEN
A. B. THIRTY ONE TEN ESTABLISHES
THE ATHLETIC TRAINING PRACTICE
ACT.
THE BILL LICENSES AND REGULATES
ATHLETIC TRAINERS UNDER THE
ATHLETIC TRAINER LICENSING
COMMITTEE. WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY THAT DOES NOT
REGULATE THE PROFESSION OF
ATHLETIC TRAINING.
IT IS A GLARING OMISSION WE ARE
THE OUT LIAR IN THE COUNTRY.
ATHLETIC TRAINERS OUR HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE OFTEN
CHARGED WITH MANAGING SERIOUS
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
SUCH AS CONCUSSIONS HEAT ILLNESS
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST AS WELL AS
MUSCULOSKELETAL SKELETAL ISSUES
LIKE DISLOCATIONS AND FRACTURES.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO LICENSING
BORDER COMMITTING CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S NO ACCURATE SYSTEMIC WAY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO REPORT
EVIDENCE OF HARM AGAINST
ATHLETIC TRAINERS OR THOSE
POSING AS ATHLETIC TRAINERS. AND
HAVE THOSE REPORTS INVESTIGATED
OR TRACKED.
THERE'S ONLY ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN ALSO PROTECTS
EMPLOYERS OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS
AND ATHLETIC TRAINERS HEMSELVES
CURRENTLY.
ATHLETIC TRAINERS WHO HAVE
OBTAINED THE PROPER EDUCATION
AND TRAINING PRACTICE IN A LEGAL
GRAY AREA. WHICH PLACES THEM AT
INCREASED RISK OF LIABILITY
EMPLOYERS OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS
IN SECTORS SUCH AS EDUCATION
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
IN OTHER INDUSTRIES.
OUR CONCERN THAT THERE'S NO
STATE SANCTIONED SCOPE OF
PRACTICE.
TO DELINEATE WHAT AFFLECK
ATHLETIC TRAINERS CAN AND CANNOT
DO. AND HEALTH CARE SETTINGS
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE OFTEN THE
ONLY PROFESSIONALS THESE
EMPLOYERS HIRE WHO ARE NOT
LICENSE.
IS CREATES A LACK OF CERTAINTY
THAT INCREASES THE EMPLOYERS
RISK OF LIABILITY. ATHLETIC
TRAINERS IN SOME SETTINGS
ESPECIALLY IN COLLEGIATE
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS AND
PERFORMING ARTS ARE REQUIRED TO
TRAVEL OUTSIDE OF THE STATE AS
PART OF THEIR JOB.
IN A GROWING NUMBER OF STATES IT
IS ILLEGAL FOR UNREGULATED
ATHLETIC TRAINERS TO PRACTICE
FOR ANY PERIOD OF TIME IN THOSE
RESPECTIVE STATES.
WHEN I WENT CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC
TRAINERS TRAVEL TO THE STATE'S
WITH THEIR TEAMS ARE COMPANIES
THEY RISK VIOLATING THOSE THE
LOSS BECAUSE THEY ARE SIMPLY NOT
REGULATED. KAREN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ANYONE CAN ACT AS AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY HAVE ANY EDUCATION
IN ATHLETIC TRAINING OR ARE
NATIONALLY SERVICE BUT
CERTIFIED.
THE STATUS QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE I
HAVE HERE WITH ME DOCTOR CINDY
CHIANG OF UCSF MEDICAL CENTER.
IZZY SALAMONE ME AND HIS MOM
SIERRA SOMEONE MONEY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS MY CHIU SAR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ASSOCIATION WHO IS HERE
TO ANSWER YOUR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS DIFFICULT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF I COULD
ASK FOR YOU TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT SO THAT WE CAN CALL OF
FOR A QUORUM COMMITTEE SECRETARY
WHICH PLEASE CALL THE.
WELL.
HERE LOW HERE BROWN.
ARAMBULA PRISON.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
JOHN.
JILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
PAUL.
GIPSON HERE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MULLIN PRESENT.
TING.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHALL
WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM AND JUST AS
A REMINDER OF JUST THREE MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
THREE MENACES UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE WHEN EVERY
RIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS MIKE CHIPS ARE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ASSOCIATION AND IN THE
SEAT MY TIME. AND TO DR CHANG
WAS A POSITION EXPERTS WORSE
MEDICINE. AND AND IS EVEN. TIMES
AND SEROTONIN WHOSE
HAD FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH
THE MISMANAGED CONCUSSION FROM
SOMEONE PRETENDING TO BE AN
ATHLETE TRAINER. BUT I'M HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
LET ME THINK ADVANCE FOR YOUR
KIND ATTENTION SO I'M AT UCSF ON
SPORTS MEDICINE POSITION.
I WAS HITTING POSITION AT THE
UC BERKELEY I'VE BEEN THE CMO
FOR TEAM USA AT PARALYMPIC AN
OLYMPIC GAMES.
SO I'M HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT.
THIS LAW BECAUSE I'M ASTONISHED
EMBARRASSED BUT THE FACT THAT WE
REMAIN THE ONLY STATE AND NATION
THAT DON'T THAT DOESN'T LICENSE
AND REGULATE OUR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS.
AND THIS LACK OF OVERSIGHT IS A
SERIOUS THREAT ARE NOT ONLY TO
ATHLETES BUT THE PUBLIC AT LARGE
A THIRD OF OUR ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED. THEY WORK
WITH THE PUBLIC IN VARIOUS A
CAPACITY SUCH AS THE MILITARY
AND OFF AND WORKPLACE SETTINGS
AND ALSO AND CLINICS WITH
PHYSICIANS LIKE LIKE WITH ME AT
UCSF.
AND CURRENTLY ANYONE.
WITHOUT THE APPROPRIATE
EDUCATION CERTIFICATION CAN ACT
AS AN ATHLETIC TRAINER PROVIDE
CARE AND THIS COPYRIGHT OUT CAN
YOU CAN RESULT IN DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE FROM SURVEYS THAT
WE'VE DONE IS ESTIMATED THAT
TWENTY PERCENT OF INDIVIDUALS
OUR HIGH SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW. WHO
ACT AS ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE NOT
QUALIFIED TO PROVIDE CARE AND
THEREFORE POTENTIALLY
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS CAN HAPPEN
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
EDUCATION?
?
AND HERE'S ANOTHER UNSETTLING
FACT THE LACK OF REGULATION
MEANS THAT ATHLETIC CHANGE FROM
OTHER STATES CAN COME TO OUR
STATE THE PRACTICE.
BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE A REGULAR
ANYBODY TO SAY HEY.
THEY PROVIDED AT THAT DANGEROUS
SITUATION OTHER STATE HERE THEY
ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE TRUE
FACTS.
A QUICK ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
THE CMA OF THE IT WAS A SAM AMSA
SAM ALL THESE NATIONAL RESPECT
WORDS NATIONS HAVE SAID.
THAT THIS LAW WE SUPPORT THIS
LAW AND WHY WOULD WE NOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL I MEAN THE PROPOSED
SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
IS IS NOT TOO BROAD FOR THE
ATHLETIC SHOES EDUCATION SO
THESE RESPECTED ORGANIZATION
SUPPORT THIS BILL SUPPORT
ATHLETIC TRAINERS LICENSURE AND
THESE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE NO
ATTORNEY MOTORS AND THERE'S NO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. AND LASTLY
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN YOU PASSED AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN. AND
THAT SAID THAT THERE IS A
MANDATORY RETURN PLAY PROTOCOL
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF A
LICENSED HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
AFTER CONCUSSION. WHAT BETTER
PERSON TO SUPERVISE THE SAFE
RETURN OF SPORT THEN NAPA
TRAINER BUT CURRENTLY ATHLETIC
TUNERS AREN'T LICENSED
IT DOESN'T FIT WITH THIS LAW
THAT WAS PASSED SO LET'S?
?
LET'S SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
LET'S ALL VOTE.
AYE FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I WAS STRUCK WITH FOUR TIMES IN
THE HEAD.
LAST YEAR.
BECAUSE OF THE MISMANAGEMENT OF.
THE ATHLETIC TRAINER I.
NOW SEVEN MONTHS MY LIFE.
I CAN'T REMEMBER ANYTHING
BETWEEN JANUARY AND JUNE.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY ISSUE THAT I
HAVE NOW BEFORE USED TO BE AN
EAGLE SCOUTS HONOR STUDENT.
NOW IT'S HARD FOR ME TO EVEN
MOST BY FIVE TIMES FIVE IN MY
HEAD.
I HAVE TO USE FINGERS I HAVE TO
WRITE IT DOWN.
AND EVEN IF THERE'S TOO MANY
NUMBERS IN A SENTENCE.
I GET A HEADACHE.
.
I CAN'T FLY BY IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO. I TRAVEL I CARE.
BUT I'VE GO LONG DISTANCES BUT.
I TRAVELED FROM THE KIDS
CALIFORNIA TO US SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY BECAUSE.
THIS IS A.
VERY BIG ISSUE.
I YEAH I HAD A VERY BRIGHT
FUTURE I HAD A VERY BIG
SCHOLARSHIP TO MY FIRST CHOICE
COLLEGE.
HAVE VANGUARD UNIVERSITY AND.
BECAUSE OF THE CONCUSSION I CAN
NINE.
I CANNOT GO LAST YEAR.
I AM.
YEAH I'VE BEEN GREATLY AFFECTED
BY THIS BECAUSE OF THE
MISMANAGEMENT OF THE ATHLETIC
TRAINER.
ON.
DO YOU THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE FOR
ADDITIONAL MEET TO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOCUMENT
VETERANS REPRESENTING THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SCORE THE BILL.
ROBERT NAYLOR REPRESENTING
STANFORD UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
YEAH SEE LOW BECAUSE I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
I BELIEVE THIS ALIMONY IS HIS
GRANDMOTHER AND TYPE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GINA VIVIANO WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO PLACE A PROGRAM ON
BEHALF OF FIFTEEN ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AND TEN SPORTS MEDICINE
POSITIONS WE SUPPORT SPELL.
WHEN I WAS BRANDED PRETTY OF THE
DIRECTOR SPORTS MEDICINE SECULAR
STATE I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LISA BARNUM UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA
DAVIS I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BRENT IN MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL KAUFMAN A HEAD OF A
TRAINER AT SECOND CITY COLLEGE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GEN NATIONALES AFFECTIONATE
GESTURE HIGH SCHOOL SACRAMENTO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MANY AS MATTHEW GREENWALD
ATHLETIC TRAINERS SEGMENT A
STATE UNIVERSITY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S BILLY DAVID SACRAMENTO
SATELLITE TRAINING AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
BUT AS MICHAEL GAVE US OTHER
TRANSECT MOSTLY IN STRONG SPORTS
BILL.
JASON BECAME ELECT TO TAKE A
QUICK MOMENT TO POINT OUT THE.
TESTIMONY HEARD EARLIER THE
ATHLETIC TRAINER THAT WAS
INVOLVED IN THE CARE WAS
ACTUALLY NOT CERTIFIED.
I JUST LIKE TO TOUCH BASES
BRIEFLY WILL.
THANK YOU VERY MOTOR BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE
READ REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
HOW BAD IT'S BEEN MY HAD KIDS IN
SPORTS IT THERE WAS NO TRAINER
COACHES WOULD TELL MY SON TO RUN
OFFICE BRAIN IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO OUR KIDS TO HAVE A QUALIFIED
TRAINER IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING?
KIDS AND ATHLETES AND ALL THE
PROTEINS HAVE ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
WASHINGTON WEEK IN SUPPORT SEEN
NO DISH NO WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. NOW LIKE TO
CALL UP WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IF
INDIVIDUALS CAN. KILEY CLEAR THE
TABLE HERE FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO COME TO THE TABLE.
AND AGAIN UP TO THREE MINUTES IN
TOTALITY FOR WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
BUT YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS IVAN ALL TOMORROW I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA. I'M
SORRY THE AMERICAN OCCUPATION
THERAPY ASSOCIATION IN THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. ARM WELL WE'RE IN
OPPOSE.
POSE POSITION ON THIS BILL AND
AND I LET ME JUST START BY
SAYING I HAVE TWO CHILDREN WHO
PLAY HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS AND SO I
APPRECIATE. THE IMPORTANCE AND
THE NEED FOR HAVING. A
LIGHTHOUSE. QUALIFIED ATHLETIC
TRAINER AT SPORTING EVENTS AND
WE DO NOT OPPOSE ATHLETIC
TRAINERS BY ANY STRETCH OF THE
IMAGINATION.
OUR CONCERNS IN THIS BILL ARE
ARE TO FALL TO ME JUST START BY.
SAYING THE FIRST ONE THAT THIS
IN THAT UNDER THIS BILL THE
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE SEEKING TO
BE PUT UNDER THE BOARD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND WE HAVE
STRONG. OBJECTIONS TO HAVING
ATHLETIC TRAINING BE PART OF THE
BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY WE
HAVE. SOME VERY DIFFERENT
EDUCATIONAL MODELS WE ARE A MAP
AT MASTERS ENTRY LEVEL PROGRAM.
TRANSITIONING TO A DOCTOR ENTRY
LEVEL PROGRAM. ATHLETIC TRAINING
AS A BACHELORS ENTRY LEVEL
PROGRAM WE HAVE DIFFERENT.
TRAINING HOURS REQUIREMENTS WE
HAVE DIFFERENT PATIENT OUTCOMES.
OUR BOARD.
LAST YEAR ALMOST DOUBLED OUR
FEES ON AL ON OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS BECAUSE HE NEEDED
MORE RESOURCES JUST TO HANDLE
THE.
CASELOAD THAT THEY HAVE ON
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AMOK THE
BOARD OF OCCUPATION THERAPY IS
CHARGED WITH THE OVERSIGHT AND
REGULATION OF AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST NOT ATHLETIC TRAINER
SO THAT IS A MAJOR CONCERN WEEK
WE THINK THAT.
JUST BY IF YOU LOOK AT THE BILL
ITSELF.
THE REQUIREMENT OF PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION SEEMS TO US MAKES
SENSE THAT IF THERE WAS GOING TO
BE ANY OVERSIGHT OVER ATHLETIC
TRAINERS. BY THE DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS IT SHOULD BE
THE MEDICAL BOARD.
IN REGARDS TO THE THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE.
WE THINK THAT IT'S MUCH TOO
BROAD.
WE THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE DEFINITION REGARDING
ATHLETIC TRAINING MORE
DEFINITION REGARDING ATHLETIC
INJURY.
ATHLETIC ACTIVITY PREVENTION
RECOGNIZE THE RECOGNITION.
RECONDITIONING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE.
THE BROAD DEFINITION OF OF
ATHLETIC ACTIVITY.
IT IT THERE'S NO MENTION OF ANY
TYPES OF OF SPORTS OR OR OR
ATHLETICS REGARDING ATHLETIC
INJURY IN LITERALLY IT IS.
YOU COULD BE YOU COULD FALL
DOWN THE STAIRS WALKING TO THIS
COMMITTEE GET HURT AND YOUR
INJURY WOULD FALL UNDER. THE
DEFINITION OF ATHLETIC ACTIVITY.
THIS BILL IN THE IN THE LANGUAGE
AS IT'S WRITTEN NOW.
IS TRYING TO FILL A HOLE IN THE
DELAY IN THE HAT IN THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT
DOES NOT EXIST.
BASED ON THIS DEFINITION.
AND.
WE WE THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE REGARDING
SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
ON ATHLETIC TRAINING AND WE
THINK THAT THIS BILL IS JUST
WERE SO FAR AWAY FROM WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE WE PREACH IT WE HAVE
TWENTY MORE SECONDS THANK YOU.
BUT YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO YUP I SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY MY NAME'S CHRIS RATE
ON CALIFORNIA.
I'M THE GOOD REPAIRS COMMITTEE
CHAIR OF CONFLICT IS THAT THEIR
POSITION I'M OUT HELP A LICENSED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND AS OUR
PRODUCT LIKE TRAINER. I SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION A. B. THIRTY THIRTY
ONE TEN.
THE REPORTS OF THE BILL ARGUE
THAT ATHLETES ARE SAFER ONCE
ABOUT THE TRAINERS ON THE
SIDELINES. THAT THERE ARE BAD
ACTORS POSING AS OTHER TRAINERS
OR IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
UNQUALIFIED. WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT HAVING A QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONAL ON THE SIDELINES
IMPORTANT TO THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF OUR ATHLETES HOWEVER
THE LANGUAGE THIS BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH ATHLETES
SPORTS. SPORTS TEAMS OR SPORTS
VENUES.
THE BILL TALK ABOUT LIKE
TRAINERS WORKING WITH PATIENTS
AND PROVIDING TREATMENT TO THEM.
LICENSURE IS NOT ALWAYS THE
RIGHT WAY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
ADDRESSING THE NUMBER ONE REASON
GIVEN FOR THIS BILL. THAT OF
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE DO NOT
CALL THEMSELVES ATHLETIC
TRAINERS UNLESS THEY HAVE
APPROPRIATE COULD CREDENTIALS.
IS LEGISLATION THAT WOULD HAVE
NO OPPOSITION.
IT ALSO ADDRESSES ANOTHER KEY
ARGUMENT THE THE MADE IN SUPPORT
A BILL THAT REGULATION IS
NECESSARY TO CARRY CALIFORNIA
BASED ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
CAN TRAVEL TO OTHER STATES.
WE ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES
WITH THE SCOPE.
AND WE WE THINK THE BILL'S IS
HIGHLY FLOPPED UP THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION UNDER ME TO
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
MIKE AND INFLATION IF YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
KATHERINE ROSS HAS GOTTEN A
CALIFORNIA CADRE OF PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS WHO ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES TO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE HUTUS IN PT'S AND REMAIN
UP AND OPPOSED THE BILL.
PAT WHALEN ELLIS MILLS NEVER SEE
HERE ON BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA PROUD
MEMBER VAST ME WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL FOR THE REASONS STATED.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE PROPOSAL AS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL.
LYNETTE BEATLES OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS IN OPPOSITION.
LARA LOPEZ OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST OPPOSITION.
CHRIS POWERS PROFESSOR AT USC
AND ALSO PRESIDENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. WE STAND OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
C. NO WITNESSES TO WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BAKER FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU I I MET QUESTION FOR
BOTH THAT PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS SO I AM FOR AND. I
HAVE HIM MY KIDS ARE IN HIGH
SCHOOL THEY PLACE SPORTS I WOULD
I WANT THEM TO HAVE ACCESS TO A
SEMI WHO'S WELL TRAINED WITH
GOOD ADVICE TO PROTECT THEM AS
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE
SPORTS.
BUT I AM CURIOUS WHY ME OUR
STATE ALSO. REALLY DOES
CREATE BARRIERS TO ENTERING THE
PROFESSION BUT ALL THE LICENSING
THAT REQUIRED USUALLY STARTS
WITH A LICENSE AND THEN IT'S
FEES AND THEN IT'S.
THE BATTLES BETWEEN WHO GETS TO
PRACTICE WHAT AND MEANWHILE
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GO
INTO THE FIELD AND CAN'T TO THEY
MIGHT BE VERY GOOD AND VERY
QUALIFIED.
I'M IN THE PAST YOU KNOW THIS
COMMITTEE AS EARLY AS THIS
LEGISLATURE'S HEARD BILLS ON
TITLE REGULATION HAVING A
CERTIFIED ATHLETIC TRAINER BE A
TITLE THAT'S REGULATED.
WHY NOT THAT STEP BEING THE MORE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DO THIS?
?
IT'S A BALANCE BETWEEN OVER
REGULATING ACCESS TO A CAREER
AND MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S A
QUALIFIED PERSON IN THAT.
PARENTS AND CONSUMERS ARE ON
NOTICE OF WHO IS CERTIFIED IN
APPROPRIATELY GIVEN THAT TITLE
AND WHO ISN'T.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION THAT
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE AROUND.
TITLE PROTECTIONS AND.
THERE IS I'VE OF.
QUITE A LONG HISTORY TO THIS
EFFORT. ALL AYE NOT OUTRIGHT
OPPOSED TO SOME.
INTERIM STEP TO GET US TO
LICENSING BUT.
I THINK THAT IS GONNA BE THE
SUBJECT OF SOME DISCUSSION THAT
THE REALITY THOUGH IS THERE ARE
SOME REALLY FUNDAMENTAL REASONS
WHY TITLE PROTECTION IS SIMPLY
NOT.
NOT SUFFICIENT I DON'T WANT IT
DIRECT THAT ADDITIONAL BARRIERS
TO PARTICIPATION.
IN THE WORKFORCE.
I THINK WHAT'S BECOME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR TO ME IS OF
MOST OF THE SITE.
ATHLETIC TRAINERS WHO ARE
OPERATING I SEE MOST NOT ALL BUT
MOST IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE ARE A RELATIVELY HIGHLY
EDUCATED. AND.
THESE FOLKS WANT.
TO BE LICENSE
THEY ARE THERE THERE'S TO UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S
BEEN COLLECTED AND FEES IN
ANTICIPATION OF. A SETTING UP A
LICENSING STRUCTURE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
WHAT
TO ELEVATE THEIR PROFESSION.
I DON'T THINK I WANTTO SEE IS
A BARRIER I THINK IT'S FRANKLY
ELEVATING OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE
ATHLETIC TRAINERS BUT ALSO
CREATES THESE PROTECTIONS WHEN
THEY. ARE ACROSS A STATE LINES
BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS.
DEFERRED MIKE PATCHES ARE WHO
CAN TALK ABOUT.
WHY TITLE PROTECTION IS SIMPLY
NOT SUFFICIENT BUT ALSO PERHAPS
YOU CAN GIVE YOU JUST A? QUICK
SNAPSHOT OF HOW MUCH WE NOW LIAR
CALIFORNIA IS IN RELATION TO THE
FORTY NINE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE A REAL REGULATORY STRUCTURE
WELL ON THE ON THAT LAST POINT
IS IS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE ANSWER IS IS SOME OBSCENE
SAVE TIME IS SOMEWHAT LESS
COMPELLING BECAUSE. WE ARE OUT
LIAR HOW MUCH WE'D LICENSE
PEOPLE AND HOW MUCH WE REQUIRE
FOR HIM A LITTLE BIT MORE AND
SHE DIDN'T THINK YOU. IN THE
WHAT'S SO INSUFFICIENT ABOUT
TITLE REGULATION.
TITLE.
OVERSIGHT AND REGULATION IS
ESPECIALLY TO REACH THAT CORRECT
BALANCE.
WITHOUT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE.
BORDER COMMITTEE YOUR BUREAU
THERE'S NO WAY AND TO ASSURE.
THAT ANYONE IS ACTUALLY
COMPLYING.
AND WHEN THEY SAY THAT THEY'RE
CERTIFIED IS JUST.
ATTESTING THAT THEY ARE WHICH
DOESN'T REALLY MEAN ANYTHING IF
SOMEONE'S COMING IN FROM OUT OF
STATUS AND HE MENTIONED.
THAT. THEY'VE LOST HER LICENSE
IN THIS. IS NOT HYPOTHETICAL
DOES HAPPEN PEOPLE COULD JUST
COMMANDED JUST TITLE PROTECTION.
THERE'S STILL NO WAY FOR THE
STATE TO GUARANTEE THAT THAT
PERSON.
S. QUALIFIED SO WITH THE
LICENSURE SET UP WE HAVE THAT
INVESTIGATORY POWER UNDERSTAND
AND THERE'S A WAYS TO FIX THAT
MINUTES MANY THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK.
CALIFORNIANS ARE
FIND ONE THAT WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE MATCH FOR DOING THAT
BUT.
THINK YOU KNOW THAT'S ONE OF
THE AREAS IN JUST YOUR.
VERY GOOD WITNESS THE GENTLEMAN
WHO HAS HAD EXPERIENCE WITH
CONCUSSIONS
AND YOU MENTION THAT IT WAS I'M
SORRY WE TO GET YOUR NAME BUT
YOU MENTIONED THAT IT WAS
MISMANAGEMENT OF THE ATHLETIC
TRAINER.
HOW WAS THAT CONCLUSION REACHED
THAT IT WAS THAT?
THAT CAUSED WHEN I'M VERY SORRY
TO HEAR HAS BEEN SEEN.
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES.
.
YOU RESTATE YOUR QUESTION ARE
JUST AND YOU WERE KIND ENOUGH TO
MENTION THAT DE EXPERIENCE YOU
HAD WAS MISMANAGEMENT FROM THE
ATHLETIC TRAINER AND. I'M WONDER
IF YOU CAN ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN THAT.
WAS WHAT KHA YOU KNOW
CONTRIBUTED TO HER WORK HAD YOU
HAD A.
AS THE LICENSED ATHLETIC TRAINER
THAT IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
BIT BETTER I'M I JUST ELABORATE
A BIT ON YOUR EXPERIENCE IF YOU
COULD YEAH SO.
FOR WOMEN FROM WHAT I TOLD FROM
THEM I PROFESSIONALS.
BY DOCTORS.
SO THAT EVEN IF I WOULD HAVE
GONE SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS I
SAID.
I HAD TO REDUCE THE SWELLING.
THEN THAT WOULD. DRAMATICALLY.
.
YEAH. THANK YOU YEAH AND I CAN'T
IF I COULD SPEAK UP I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE.
AS AS WELL AS HIS MOTHER HE WAS
HIT IN THE HEAD SO SEVERELY HE
COULDN'T SEE HE WAS LAID OUT
FLAT ON ITS BACK.
AND THE ONLY TREATMENT HE GOT
WAS ARE YOU HOPING TO GET UP AND
PLAY.
THERE WAS.
YOU KNOW NO OTHER TREATMENT
AFTER HIS SECOND HIT WHEN HE
PULLED HIMSELF OUT OFF THE
FIELD.
THE TRAINER TOLD IN THE SET ON
THE BENCH AND HELL BE FINE. A
CONCERNED FATHER FROM THE STANDS
ACTUALLY WENT DOWN HE WAS UNABLE
TO STATE HIS NAME WHERE HE LIVE
MY NAME MY PHONE NUMBER.
THE FATHER HAD YOU SEE VERY ON
HIS PHONE TO CALL ME. AND FIND
OUT WHERE WE LIVE TO BRING HIM
TO ME. RIGHT TO COME TO THE
HOSPITAL HE WAS ADMITTED FOR
FIVE DAYS. AND IT WAS THAT
SECOND IMPACT ON HIS HEAD. THAT
COST HIS PERMANENT BRAIN DAMAGE
UNDERSTAND THANK YOU IT JUST
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE WERE
RESPONDING TO THAT TYPE OF.
INCIDENT WITH THE RIGHT.
SOLUTION AND SO I'M VERY SORRY
FOR THAT AND GRATEFUL THAT YOU
TRAVELED OUT TO SHARE THAT WITH
US IN IF IF IT JUST IT JUST OF
THE OPPOSITION MISTER ALL
SUMMER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I I I'M NOT REALLY
UNDERSTANDING I KNOW THAT THAT
THAT'S NOT A.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS PART
THE OCCUPATIONAL BOARD
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY BOARD BE
THE ONE TO OVERSEE BUT WHAT I
HEARD IS BECAUSE.
FEES MIGHT BE CHARGED MORE BUT
PRESUMABLY THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LICENSE BUT ALSO BE PAYING FEES
AND SOMETHING ABOUT BECAUSE
THERE'S AN ENTRY LEVEL AT
BACHELOR VERSUS MASTER A
DOCTORATE Y. DOES THAT MAKE THE
OCCUPATIONAL BOARD NOT THE RIGHT
PLACE.
BUT WHAT'S I WAS JUST TRYING TO
POINT OUT SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
ATHLETIC TRAINING AND.
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY THE THAT
THE PRIMARY DIFFERENCE IS THERE
IS IN THE PRACTICE
ITSELF
AND. THE THE PATIENT OUTCOMES IN
THE FIFTH AND THE FIFTH IN THE
TRAINING THAT IS REQUIRED.
OF OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS
VERSES.
ACT VERSES ATHLETIC TRAINING
THEY'RE NOT THEY ARE. THEY ARE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
PROFESSIONS
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY.
NOT
BEING AS FOCUSED AS THEY NEED TO
BE AND THE CONCERNS OFF FROM A
FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE OF THEIR
BEING UPWARD PRESSURE.
ON OUR OWN LICENSING FEES TO
CONTINUE TO INCREASE BECAUSE OF
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD AS WELL
ON ATHLETIC TRAINING AND SO IT'S
IT'S A TWO FOLD CONCERN.
.
THANK YOU FOR RESPONDING TO
QUESTIONS OF.
SURE ASSEMBLY WOMAN TRY
APPRECIATE QUESTION BECAUSE THIS
IS.
.
THE LOW BOTTOM CONTENTION HERE
YOU KNOW THAT.
THERE WAS PRIOR LEGISLATION
VERY SIMILAR TO THIS BILL THAT
C. BUT NAM. PORT OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY SUPPORTED.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO THE PROCESS
NOW I GUESS.
THIS THE ITEM IS IN THEIR
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE BUT I
EXPECT THAT C. BOT WILL.
COME OUT IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE THEY WANT THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO AT SO I.
BOB I JUST WANT TO SUGGEST THAT
I REALLY DO BELIEVE AND THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY WITH THIS WITH
THIS BALLOT LOTS OF RESEARCH I
BELIEVE SEE BUT ACTUALLY IS THE
APPROPRIATE.
I HAS A CAPACITY TO DO THIS
OVERSIGHT OF BUT I AM. OPEN TO
ANY AND ALL DISCUSSIONS TO GET
THIS ONCE AND FOR ALL ITS CITY
AND SO ON AFTER MANY MANY YEARS
OF ATTEMPTS.
WE REMAIN.
THIS OUT WIRES JUST.
WELL IT'S A APPARENT OF KIDS WHO
ARE INVOLVED IN SPORTS THAT THAT
ARE OUT RUNNING AROUND IN AND
HAVE AN IMPACT IN AND ATHLETES
THEMSELVES I'M. GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON IT I HATE WE
THINK WE NEED TO NARROWLY TAILOR
AS MUCH AS WE CAN I THINK THAT
TITLE REGULATION THAT YOU KNOW
THIS TYPE OF STEPS TO BE REALLY
GOOD TO HAVE AS PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AND.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SOMEONE
BAKER ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS.
BIRTH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ALSO I WANT TO APPLAUD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ADDRESSING
WHAT IS THE IT IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AN ISSUE.
THAT.
THE TESTIMONY THAT.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO STEP UP AND
DO SOMETHING IS THAT WERE THE
LAST STATE.
AND SO.
THAT SHOULD BE REASON ENOUGH
RIGHT THERE TO BE ABLE TO COME
UP WITH THE ACTION.
ABSOLUTE BEST.
OR WHATEVER WE NEED TO DO TO
MOVE FORWARD SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS OUT
AGAIN.
AND I DO LIKE YOUR REFERENCE TO
GETTING IT INTO THE END ZONE.
HOPEFULLY YOUR ATHLETIC TRAINER
CAN GET YOU THERE.
.
I THINK OPPOSITION.
I HAVE MISTER REED.
I YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU WERE A
THERAPIST AND THAT YOU ALSO ARE
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER.
SO IN A NOT SURE WHAT CAPACITIES
ON BOTH SIDES YOU KNOW TO WHAT
EXTENT YOU WORK.
IN YOUR PROFESSION BUT.
HAS THERE EVER BEEN A TIME
WHERE YOU WERE AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER. AND YOU WERE CALLED
UPON AND THE PERSON YOU WERE
WORKING WITH.
YOU WOULD HAVE CONSIDERED A
PATIENT.
ARE.
DOES IT BECOME A BIT SEMANTIC
GOAL OR. THAT I MEAN WE JUST GOT
DONE HEARING A BILL ABOUT.
PETS BEING CALLED PATIENTS.
SO ARE NOT CALLING PEOPLE THAT
ARE INJURED OR. WHATEVER PETS
BUT.
.
MUSIC CANNOT BE A PATIENT WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO
SO I WOULD SAY THAT THAT THE
LARGEST DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO IS ATHLETES WHEN THEY'RE
PARTICIPATING IN ORGANIZED FOR.
THEY'VE GOT THEIR PRE
PARTICIPATION SCREENINGS THAT
HAVE CLEARED THEM OF YEAH I
UNDERLINED ICAL CONDITIONS SO
WHEN THE ATHLETE DOES GO DOWN
THE FIELD. YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH SOMEBODY WHO PRIOR
TO GOING DOWN WAS A HEALTHY
INDIVIDUAL THAT DIDN'T HAVE ANY
UNDERLYING
ACTIONS OR IF THEY DID HAVE AN
UNDERLYING CONDITION YOU'RE
AWARE OF WHAT THE CONDITION WAS.
WHAT I'M A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
PRICING IN THE CLINIC AND A
PATIENT WALKS AND? WHO MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE SEEN A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL PREVIOUSLY FOR THAT
CONDITION?
I GOT A BILL THAT DETERMINE ARE
THERE THINGS THAT UNDERLYING
THAT COULD BE AFFECTING WHAT'S
WHAT THE PRESENTATION IS. AND
THEN MAKE DETERMINATIONS ON IS
APPROPRIATE FOR ME BILL TO TREAT
THAT PERSON IS IT MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR ME TO REFER THAT
PATIENT ONTO ANOTHER. AND
MEDICAL PROVIDER AT THAT POINT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMAN EGGMAN.
THANK YOU UP WHEN YOU SING UP
PERSONS FOUND TO BE LOCATED ON
THE FIELD YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN YOU THE DOCTOR THEY JUST
CHECK THAT BOX IT'S A. YEAH GOOD
SHAPE.
MY EXEMPTS THE MAJORITY IN
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO FOR LIKE A PRE
SCORED SKEPTICISM AND UP TO GO
TO THE SPORT YOU HAVE TO GO BY
AND IT'S I MEAN.
IT IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO.
YEAH I'M REFERRING TO THE
PARTICIPATION SCREENINGS ARE
DONE YA SOMETIMES THE PHYSICIAN
DOES JUST CHECK THE BOX AND SAYS
YEAH THAT'S ALRIGHT. BUT IF THE
PHYSICIANS DOING THEIR JOB
APPROPRIATELY THEY'RE ACTUALLY
TALK WITH PAGE OF FINDING OUT DO
THEY HAVE ANY MUSCLES GOT
CONCERNS THERE LOOK AT THEIR LAB
WORK. THEY'RE LOOKING AT PRIOR
IT THINGS THAT COME UP. AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE PATIENT.
TRULY IS.
APPROPRIATELY PARTICIPATE IN
ATHLETICS.
OKAY I MEAN I THINK WE'VE ALL
HAD.
CHINA'S FORMS HAD THOSE FORMS
TURNED IN AND ANNA AND I THINK
THERE'S A PROBLEM A VARIETY OF
OF WAYS IT DOES A COMPLETED.
BOMB.
TO COME TO STATE YOUR PREMISE ON
THAT.
I. AM I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
AROUND JUST AND JUST LOOKING AT
THE QUALIFICATIONS AND WHAT
OTHER STATES ARE DOING. ARE THE
MAJORITY OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE PRACTICING OR
THE CERTIFIED UNDER THE NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION BECAUSE THERE'S A
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION THAT
THEY'LL HAVE TO BE. SORT OF
ITEMS I CORRECT AND SO DO WE
KNOW DO WE HAVE REQUIREMENTS
THAT EVERYBODY. PRACTICING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS PORTRAIT
NATIONAL CERTIFIES. YES A GOING
TO TURN THIS OVER TO MIKE'S ARE
EVEN GIVE YOU THE PRECISE.
.
RUN DOWN ON THE CURRENT STATUS
OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND THEIR
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION.
SO.
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT AND
THAT'S WHAT PART OF WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO IS ESTABLISH
REQUIREMENTS.
I AM IN ALL HONESTY THE MAJORITY
OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
OUR CERTIFIED VETERAN PUEDEN
WORKINGS AFFECT TRAINERS.
AND BUT AS DR CHIANG MENTION
THROUGH CI HAVE SURVEYS WE KNOW
THAT OVER. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
OVER TWENTY PERCENT OF PEOPLE
CALLING THEMSELVES AN ETHIC
TRAINER IN A HIGH SCHOOL DO NOT
HAVE THE PROPER QUALIFICATIONS
AND TRAINING. SOMETIMES THAT IS
KNOWING AND THE SCHOOL.
YES WE HAVE SOME BE CERTIFIED
WHO ACTUALLY ISN'T.
IN DO WE HAVE WE HAVE
DIFFERENCES IN IN TREATMENT
OUTCOMES FROM THOSE WHO ARE
CERTIFIED NOT CERTIFIED WE'VE
WILL HAVE TO STE.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT CERTIFIED
WOULDN'T KNOW HOW TO EVEN BEGIN
DOING THAT SO THERE REALLY ISN'T
A WAY TO COMPARE THOSE APPLES
AND ORANGES.
AND SILVA SMOG AGAIN ON THIS
IDEA OF GOING TO A FULL
LICENSURE. IT MEANS YOU'RE
INTERVENING STEP WHEREYOU COULD
EVERYBODY IT WOULD HAVE TO BE
GRANTED TO BE CERTIFIED.
WHO'S PRACTICING THAT.
CERTAINLY OPEN TO HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION I WANT US TO GET TO
FULL LICENSURE I'D LOVE TO DO IT
WITH THIS BILL. THIS YEAR
POSSIBLY CAN MAKE A STATEMENT
ABOUT IT AND AND FINALLY GET IT
DONE.
BUT LOOK I.
AND.
TALKING WITH ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS THING I THINK
THEY'RE A COUPLE THINGS THAT WE
CAN MOST CERTAINLY TAKE CARE OF
I THINK THERE ARE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL SCOPE ISSUES WITH.
OF FISCAL AS THERE PESTS.
IN THE CORPORATE ENVIRONMENT
THAT ARE REALLY DIFFICULT TO
DEAL WITH.
SO WE ARE GOING TO BE WORKING
THROUGH ALL OF THOSE ISSUES.
THIS WEEK
BUT.
I JUST THINK IF WE.
LEAVE THIS ISSUE YET ANOTHER
YEAR.
AND DON'T MOVE FORWARD.
A CHEST UP POINTS TO THE FACT
THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S INCAPABLE OF
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE AND I
DON'T ACCEPT THAT.
WE HAVE TO FIX THIS CAN AND.
AND THEN THESE ATHLETIC TRAINERS
WOULD BE PASSED SUPERVISED BY
WHOM THE LICENSED ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ANY SUPERVISION.
WHICH MIKE WOULD YOU SPEAK TO
THAT THAT. OVERSIGHT P. SO
AUTHOR TRAINERS ARE REQUIRED SO
PEOPLE ARE CERTIFIED FOR THE
MOST PART AND SOON IN CALIFORNIA
ARE WORKING UNDER THE DIRECTION
OF PHYSICIAN.
CERTAINLY RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
MANDATE FOR THAT.
AND THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT
AND AGAIN ALL THESE MEDICAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN SUPPORT. OF
THAT AND SAYING THAT THAT TIE IS
ACCEPTABLE WE'VE ACTUALLY TAKEN
SOME AMENDMENTS THIS WEEK AND
PROPOSE THOSE TO SOME GROUPS.
TO DO THAT AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT YOU KNOW FOR LOOKING AT.
NO THE OUTCOMES I MEAN I THINK.
A STORY THAT YOU HEARD TODAY
THAT'S THE TYPE OF THE OUTCOME
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT AND
THAT DOES.
OCCUR WITH THESE UNQUALIFIED
PEOPLE MANAGING THESE COMPLEX
ISSUES.
AND THEN THAT WOULD I MEAN UNDER
THE SUPERVISION OF A PHYSICIAN
AND WOOD ADDRESS YOUR ISSUE
ABOUT IF YOUR PHYSICAL THERAPIST
OMING OR. NOTHING TRAINER
COMING TO KNOW THAT OPPOSITION
HAS BASICALLY OKAYED THAT PERSON
FOR.
YEAH LET ME SPEAK TO THE
OVERSIGHT ISSUE JUST A LITTLE
BIT HERE. SO AB THIRTY ONE TEN
AUTHORIZES AN ATHLETIC TRAINER
DO TREAT THEIR. PATIENTS.
UNDER THE PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION
THE SUPERVISION REQUIRED CAN BE
AS LITTLE AS A.
.
A CATHOLIC TRAINING PROTOCOL
THERE'S BEEN DEVELOP BETWEEN THE
ATHLETIC TREND THE POSITION THAT
SAYS YEAH IF YOU HAVE AN ANKLE
SPRAIN.
IF YOU'RE PENSION PLANS WITH
DESIGNS AND AS AN ANKLE SPRAIN
TREAT THIS PATIENT APPROPRIATELY
FOR AS LONG AS YOU FEEL THAT
YOUR COUPLED TREAT FOR. RIGHT AS
A PHYSICAL THERAPIST I CAN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND I HAVE
SOME DOUBT IT BECAUSE THAT
THAT'S HOW WE DO EVERYTHING YOU
NURSES EVERYTHING EVERYBODY ELSE
THERE ARE PROTOCOLS ESTABLISH
WHICH IS NOW SUPERVISION OCCURS
SO. IT BY PROCEDURE.
ALRIGHT THINKING SMALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOCTOR AND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND.
.
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO IF IF I
COULD CONTINUE TO PROBE ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON'S
QUESTION I THOUGHT IT WAS. A
VERY GOOD ONE AND WAS WONDERING
IF WE COULD HEAR FROM DOCTORS
CHIANG WHO SPOKE EARLIER TODAY.
AND HAVE HER ADDRESS THAT
SPECIFIC ISSUE.
BUT BEFORE WHILE SHE'S COMING UP
I WANTED TO THANK THE
INFORMATIONAL NATURE OF THIS
ISSUE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US AS A BODY TO. HEAR AND
DELIBERATE WITH YOU AND TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN
JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN THIS MANNER TODAY.
THIS RED BUTTON GETS ME EVERY
TIME. PERTAINING TO THE USE OF
ATHLETE OR PATIENT SO I JUST
CHAIRED A. INNER SOCIAL ASIAN
DOCUMENT OF MULTIPLE
ORGANIZATIONS
ABOUT THE MANAGEMENT OF
MEDICATIONS IN THE SPORTS
MEDICINE SETTING.
WE ALL AGREE THAT WE USE THE
TERM PATIENT AND NOT ATHLETE.
AND THE FACT IS IS THAT. A. YOU
KNOW EVERY EVERY UP PATIENT
EVERY ATHLETE IS A PATIENT EVERY
PATIENTS THE ATHLETE WE WE. LOOK
AT THAT WHOLE SCOPE OF PRACTICE
AS SOMEONE WHO COMES WAS FOR
CARE AS A PATIENT.
IN TERMS OF THE THE IDEA THAT
EVERY PATIENT.
BUT THE ATHLETIC TRAINER SIS HAS
A PRE PARTICIPATION FISCAL
CLEARANCES NOT TRUE. ATHLETIC
TRAINERS WORK IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS WHERE THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW THAT PATIENT.
THEY DON'T KNOW.
IF THAT PATIENTS HAD A A PRE
PARTICIPATION PHYSICALS CETERA.
AND THE THING IS IS THAT THEY
HAVE THE EDUCATION AND THE
TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO. MANAGE.
THAT.
SITUATION APPROPRIATELY AND
AVOID A POTENTIALLY CATASTROPHIC
SITUATION IN THE CASE OF BUSY.
THERE WAS A.
PRESUMED ATHLETIC TRAINER WHO
DID NOT HAVE THAT NECESSARY
EDUCATION LICENSURE.
OF COURSE NOT LICENSE OR BECAUSE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
EDUCATION.
AND CERTIFICATION AND THEREFORE
DIDN'T KNOW. HOW TO MANAGE HIS
HEAD INJURY?
WHICH LED TO WHAT HAPPENED WITH
HIM.
I WILL SAY THAT.
THE PHYSICAL THERAPY. THAT IN
THE REAL WORLD.
IN THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN PRACTICING IN THE
REAL WORLD. WE ALL WORK AS A
TEAM.
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS ATHLETIC
TRAINERS OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS
PHYSICIANS.
WE ARE A TEAM WHETHER NOT
WORKING WITH A HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETE.
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE IN LIBYAN.
OR SOMEONE WHO IS PLAYING
TENNIS.
AND GETS INJURED.
WE WORK AS A TEAM AND I HAVE
LETTERS OF SUPPORT FROM MY FISKE
THERAPISTS WHO SUPPORT THIS
LICENSURE.
AND THERE'S NO POLITICS INVOLVED
IT IS A HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
PATIENTS. AND THAT'S WHY WE WORK
AND TO. DO THE WORK THAT WE
DEAL.
AND THIS IS WHY I'M COMING FROM
OHIO. IF I CAME TO CALIFORNIA.
TO SEEK A MEDICAL LICENSE TO
PRACTICE AND OHIO I DID%
SOMETHING UNETHICAL IT WOULD
BEEN REPORTED. IF I WOULD HAVE
COME TO CALIFORNIA.
AND ASK FOR LICENSE THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE
LOOKED. AT OHIO TO SAY HEY.
THERE'S SOMETHING GOING ON WITH
HER WE'RE NOT GONNA GIVE HER
LICENSE I COULDN'T PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. I WOULDN'T HARM ANY
MORE PATIENTS.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT AFFECT
TRAINERS WHO HAVE DONE SOMETHING
A TRANSGRESSION IN THEIR STATE
CAN COME TO CALIFORNIA. AND
PRACTICE AND THERE'S NO
LICENSING AUTHORITIES SAY. HEY
THIS PERSON IS UNSAFE.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN CARE OF
PATIENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR AND I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE WHETHER WE CALL
THEM.
PATIENTS OR WITNESSES OR IS THE.
HOW IMPORTANT HIS STORY WAS TO
ALL OF US HERE TODAY AND I JUST
DIDN'T WANT TO MOMENTS TO GO BY
WITHOUT YOU KNOWING HOW MOVING
YOUR TESTIMONY?
SO THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AS
RECALL THIS IS THE. TESTIMONY
ONLY PRESENTATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOLUNTEER WISH TO CLOSE.
JUST THINKING YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR TAKING YOUR TIME TO SIT DOWN
ME AND AND WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THESE DIFFICULT ISSUES I
ANTICIPATE WILL BE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND DEFINITIONS
AND.
THESE THESE TOUGH A SCOPE
ISSUES BUT I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE A BREAKTHROUGH
ON THIS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT THE MERITS OF MY GOALS
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. THE
PROFESSION AND EMPLOYERS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S TO THE
COUNTRY'S MOST POPULOUS STATE.
CAN FINALLY JOINED THE RANKS OF
ALL OTHER STATES AND REGULATE.
THE PROFESSION OF ATHLETIC
TRAINING AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM COULD
MEMBERS AND THINKING ALL
WITNESSES SPEAKING ON THIS TOPIC
IN FOR COMING ALL THE WAY HERE
TO OUR STATE CAPITOL SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING.
WHEN OUR MOVE BACK IN. UP ORDER.
.
AND THAT IS.
THEN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO I
SEE A SEMI THEIR BILL QUIRK
PRESENT AND THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWENTY.
I CAN UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND UP TO
THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO EXPRESS FULLY.
PRESLEY STATE.
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
SUPERSEDE.
STATE SECONDHAND SMOKING LAWS.
MY VOICE IS GOING I APOLOGIZE.
I THINK I WILL LEAVE.
THE.
TESTIMONY TO MY EXPERTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A TO BE AS
BRIEF AS YOU WISH ABSOLUTELY
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LEGAL
O'DONNELL GOT HERE BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF OAKLAND. THE SPONSOR IN
THE CITY OF EMERYVILLE STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE THINK SILLY MEMBER
QUIRK FOR ALL HIS HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL IN COMMITTEE STAFF
ALSO.
THE CITY OF OAKLAND YOU KNOWS
WHEN THE FIRST CITIES HAVE A
WELL REGULATED.
HIGHLY FUNCTIONING CANNABIS
PROGRAM THE CITY'S CANNABIS
INDUSTRY NOT ONLY PROVIDES HIGH
QUALITY JOBS BUT ALSO REVENUE TO
THE CITY.
UNFORTUNATELY UNDER CURRENT LAW
TEMPORARY EVENTS THAT INVOLVE
THE SALE OF CANNABIS CAN ONLY
HAPPEN AT A COUNTY FAIR GROUND
OR DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION VENUE. OF WHICH IS
CITY LIKE OAKLAND HAS NEITHER.
AB TWENTY TWENTY IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL AS IT MERELY EXPANDS
UPON CURRENT LAW BY ALLOWING
THESE TEMPORARY EVENTS TO BE
HELD IN ANY VENUE. EXPRESSLY
APPROVED BY LOCAL JURISDICTION.
THE WAY THE RAGS ARE WRITTEN NOW
THE CITY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
SAY YES OR NO TO A SPECIAL
EVENT.
JUST IT'S SEVERELY LIMITED AS
WHERE THAT EVENT CAN TAKE PLACE.
IN A NUTSHELL AB TWENTY TWENTY
WELL CITIES TO MAINTAIN LOCAL
CONTROL AND GRANTS FOR RETURNEES
ROOFS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS CAN A
CRAFT AND TERROR ATTACK. A VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. AND I
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER DELUCA AND JUST
SIMPLY SAY THAT.
AB TWENTY TWENTY EXPANDS
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
CERTAINLY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS DESPERATELY NEEDED AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS TRYING TO FIND
AN APPROPRIATE PATHWAY TO
COMPLIANCE. IT ALSO PRESERVES A
CORNERSTONE OF THE MEDICINAL AND
UNTIL USE FRAMEWORK ENACTED LAST
YEAR BY UPHOLDING LOCAL CONTROL.
UNDER TWENTY TWENTY SPECIAL
EVENTS AUTHORIZING COMMERCIAL
CANADA SALES AND CONSUMPTION
WOULD STILL REQUIRE APPROVAL BY
THE APPROPRIATE CITY OR COUNTY
AND MAINTAIN CRITICAL PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PUT.
FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE WE
SHOULD PUT THE BILL THANK YOU.
IT YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT CAME IN AFFILIATION FOR
THE RECORD IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
MICHAEL HAWKINS ON BEHALF OF
KEIRA OF MANUFACTURING
DISTRIBUTION COMPANY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
POSTED WITH THE RURAL COUNTIES
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THE RECENT SET OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN AT
OUR REQUEST THANK YOU.
SURCHARGE ON DIVORCE ABOUT THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR PETER HEUSEN
ON THE BEHALF NORTHERN LIGHTS
MUSIC GROUP AS WELL AS A RANGE
OF STAKEHOLDERS IN THE MUSIC
AND.
CANNABIS INDUSTRY FROM AROUND
THE STATE AB TWENTY TWENTY
PROVIDES A CLEAR AND REGULATED
FRAMEWORK FOR LARGE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO DECIDE WHAT
CANNABIS SALES AND CONSUMPTION
APPROPRIATE WITHIN THEIR SENIOR
COUNTY.
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE CURRENT
FRAMEWORK AND STILL REQUIRES FOR
STATE LICENCES IN ORDER TO EVEN
BE ELIGIBLE FOR SALE THAT
EVENTS.
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
TWENTY RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SAU IBRAHIM I'M
A PROUD SUPPORTER OF AB TWENTY
TWENTY AB TWENTY TWENTY POWERS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IS SET CLEAR
PRIMERS ARE AROUND CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION SINCE SALES WHILE A
KILLING. AND ALIGNING WITH STATE
LAW THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
UNDERGROUND CANNABIS EVENTS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE IN THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR MUCH NEEDED GUIDANCE
THIS IS AN ARE NECESSARY NEXT
STEP OF CALIFORNIANS A MARKET
LEADER IN THIS INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIR
BICYCLES WITH QUE THREE
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF FLOW
KANA CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION AND
PROCESSING DELIVERY COMPANY AND
COVER CANVASSED LOW RELIANCE
BOTH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NICK CAST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAMPUS TOURISM
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING QUE MEATBALL
BEHALF OF WE DROP CANNABIS
DELIVERY IN SUPPORT.
JASON BROWN WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
WHERE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF
OF EASE SOLUTIONS ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY ARGYLE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A THERAPEUTIC
ALTERNATIVE AS STATE LICENSES
SPENCER HERE IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND WE SUPPORT ALSO AND.
BILLS THAT HELP WITH THE
TRANSITION OF OUR INDUSTRY INTO
THE REGULATED MARKET THANK YOU.
MORE MP NOW WITH THE UNITED
CANADA'S BUSINESS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OUR WE THINK THAT BILL
IS GOOD HAD THANK YOU FOR
KEEPING THAT. RETAILERS TO
CONTINUE THAT SALES ARE AT THIS
RENTS.
THANKS FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR.
DAVID CAN TURN A CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURE ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
DALE GEARING THEIR WITH
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND THERE'S BEEN A MOTION.
WILL NOW ASK
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION FEEL FREE TO COME TO
THE. TABLE AND I HAVE ALLOW FOR
OF THE TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES OF
OPPOSITION SURPLUS WHEN
EVERYBODY THOUGHT TIM GIVES
MAKING CAN'T STUDY CANCER ACTION
NETWORK AYE WE HAD BEEN.
POSING AS AMENDED WHICH TO
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR.
AT IN THE.
.
HE'S NOT IN THE LABOR CODE SO WE
REMEMBER OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES ADDITIONALLY TUITION
PICKING UP THE.
CARILLO GET AND I AM IN TOTAL
OPPOSITION OF THIS BECAUSE
FAMILIES GO TO COUNTY FAIRS.
AND IT'S NOT FAIR THAT THEY HAVE
TO BE FOR IS TO BE DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE.
WE NEED TO STOP.
BE ENFORCED TO PUT UP WITH THIS
INDUSTRY AT ALL LEVELS.
DAVID
PUSH THEIR SELF FOREIGNERS AYE
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER.
I HAVE A TEACHER.
WITH VICTIMS.
OF THESE PEOPLE.
ACTUALLY KIDS THAT HAVE DIED
BECAUSE OF THIS INDUSTRY.
PLEASE STOP.
AND LET US HAVE FUN AT OUR
FAILURES.
REACHED OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TINA QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME A
SUMMER QUIRK DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
S. B. ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
MOTION AND A WILL ENTERTAIN A
SECOND.
A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
EGGMAN.
THIS DOESN'T CHOI IN AYE
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE SECTOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LOW AYE AYE LOW AYE BRO.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDER.
IRWIN.
MULLIN.
TING.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
A SUMMER QUIRK WILL NOW PUT
MOVE ON THAT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX WHICH IS YOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE. AND
AGAIN GIVEN THE POSITION THAT
YOU'RE IN FEEL FREE TO BE AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE OR DEFERRED
TO.
YOUR WITNESSES AND SUPPORT HAS
BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT ONE
OF YOUR READY. AUTUMN.
RIGHT NOW.
A LAB.
MAY TEST.
CANNABIS
THAT'S GROWN FOR PERSONAL
MEDICAL USE.
BUT IT CAN'T.
TEST CANNABIS.
GROWN.
OUR PERSONAL ADULT USE.
ARE AT LEAST IT'S AMBIGUOUS
WHETHER THEY CAN OR NOT WE WANT
TO REMOVE THAT AMBIGUITY. AND
MAKE SURE THAT LAB CONTEST FOR
ANY TYPE OF PERSON WHO REALLY
USE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
YES I DEAL GARY NORTH CALIFORNIA
NORMAL ARM THIS IS A MATTER OF
THE CONSUMER RIGHT TO CONSUMER
ACCESS ARE. KICK CANNABIS IS NOW
LEGAL FOR ALL ADULTS. ARE AND.
CONSUMERS ARE TO BE ABLE TO TEST
THEY ARE OUR PRODUCTS OR OUR OWN
WHAT WHATEVER THEY HAVE OBTAINED
PEOPLE ARE ALLOWED TO GROW THEIR
OWN. OR THEY MAY GET SAMPLES
FROM FRIENDS AND THEY DON'T
ALWAYS KNOW WHAT SENATE I CAN
TELL YOU HAVING. ARE CO WRITTEN
A HANDBOOK ABOUT THIS THAT ARE.
CALM GROWERS HAVE A LOT OF
INTEREST IN FINDING OUT WHAT'S.
ODD THE PLAN THEY'RE INTERESTED
TO KNOW WHETHER THERE'S BACTERIA
OR FUNGUS ON CONTAMINATION
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN THE
POTENCY OF WHAT THEY PRODUCED.
ARE AND THERE'S SOME SUBSTANCES
IN CANNABIS I CAN'T DIAL WHICH
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF ARE WHICH
IS A GREAT NAME MEDICAL INTEREST
ACTUALLY. I OUR WHICH CAN ONLY
BE.
DETECTED BY TESTING
SO ARE.
IF.
MEDICAL CONSUMERS CAN HAVE THEIR
MEDICINE TEST AND THERE'S NO
REASON THAT GENERAL ADULT USERS
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO SO AMY
TAKEN SOME BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I WILL JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
AND REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAKING ON
THE OPPOSITION PACIFIC COME ON
MY PHONE.
CARILLO GETS AND NO OFF BY
SAYING NO TO THIS BILL.
RESPECTFULLY BECAUSE THE PARTY
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN LYING ABOUT.
HOW THIS?
POTTER HAS AFFECTED THEM.
AND MOST OF THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
THROUGH GEORGE SOROS.
AND I KNOW YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT
HIM SOME OF YOU.
AND SO THE LIES HAVE BEEN SAID
ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO START SAYING THE
TRUTH AND THESE TESTING LABS ARE
ONLY IN THEIR. BEST INTERESTS.
AND IT'S CAUSING TOO MUCH DAMAGE
IN TOO MANY LIVES ARE BEING
LOST.
SO PLEASE RESPECTFULLY SAY NOW.
SAVE LIVES FOR A CHANGE INSTEAD
OF KILLING THEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. SEEM
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME OF FROM THE COMMITTEE A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK OF THERE
HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND IF YOU WISH TO CLOSE TO ME
TO SELL. OF SEEING THAT THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION A SECOND THIS DOES
ENJOY AN AYE RECOMMENDATION.
UGLY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
LOW AYE LOW EYEBROW.
BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER NOW BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MULLIN.
TING.
THE GROUP WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THEN FINALLY WILL MOVE ON
FOR YOUR LAST BILL PRESENTATION
WHICH IS ON THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN AT THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINETY NINE IS SOMEWHERE
COURT THIS DOES ENJOY AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT MANY OF YOU ARE
READY.
ALRIGHT.
CURRENT REGULATIONS.
REQUIRE THE PLANTS BE
DESIGNATED USES TELL YOU SIR
MEDICAL USE FROM THE TIME
THEY'RE BORN.
BOB THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THAT.
JUST DISTINCT.
MISTER RAND WILL TESTIFY.
COULD YOU VERY MUCH UP TO THREE
MINUTES THREE MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND THREE
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION EXCUSE ME
MISTER RAND MARTIN. YES.
I CAN BE MISTER RAND AROUND HERE
THAT'S OKAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MERGE RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL BUT I
KNOW I. THE INDUSTRY GENERALLY
SUPPORTS I'M MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
YOU ALL PASSED LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR THE CREATED THE A IN THE M.
LICENSING PATHWAY. WHAT THE
BUREAU DID IN DECEMBER IN THE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WAS TO
CREATE A FIRE WALL BETWEEN THOSE
TWO PATHWAYS WHICH MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR?
SOMEBODY WHO'S WORKING IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD TO.
TO ENGAGE CONDUCT.
BUSINESS COMMERCIALLY WAS
SOMEBODY IN THE ADULT FIELD AND
VICE VERSA WHAT THIS MEANS NOW
IS THAT WHEN THE PLANT IS THIS
BIG AT THE CULTIVATOR IT MUST BE
DESIGNATED AS AN ADULT USE OR
MET MEDICAL USE PLANT. AND NEVER
SHALL IT CHANGED FROM THAT POINT
UNTIL IT IS SOLD TO A CONSUMER
EITHER AS A PLANT OR AS AAS A.
MANUFACTURE PRODUCT AT THE END
OF THE LINE AND THAT MAKES IT
OPERATIONALLY INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGE. FOR OUR BUSINESSES TO
OPERATE ON BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE MARKET IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE DOWN THE PATH. I'M WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO BE NIMBLE ENOUGH
TO MOVE THE PRODUCT FROM ONE
SIDE TO THE OTHER WE DO OTHER
TRACK AND TRACE SYSTEM DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT WE WILL KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE THAT PRODUCT CAME FROM AND
WHERE IT'S GOING. AT EVERY POINT
BUT UNDER THIS BILL.
IT WOULD ALLOW US TO MOVE
ACROSS THE FIREWALL ON BETWEEN A
MAN AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE OF
OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITIES THIS
YEAR TO ADDRESS ME WHEN I THINK
THE AUTHOR. IN ADDITION TO WHAT.
MISTER ROUNDS MARTIN HAD TO SAY.
WE WHICH IS ECHO THE FACT THAT
THIS WOULD.
REDUCE THE SIGNIFICANT COSTS ON
INDUSTRY AND THAT IS REQUIRED
UNDER THIS PARTICULAR MODEL AYE
TO IMPLEMENT TWO SEPARATE PATHS.
ONE FOR MEDICINAL ONE FOR ADULT
USE AND THAT'S EXTREMELY KATA
COSTLY AND ADDS DUPLICATING OUR
OPERATIONAL SYSTEMS.
IS ALSO A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE
GIVEN WE DO HAVE LIMITATIONS IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE ARE ALLOWED TO
DO AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES I WOULD
ALSO NOTE TOO THAT.
THIS ENSURES ACCESS
BY ALLOWING THE CROSSOVER
BETWEEN A AND M. IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALLOW WE CAN
GUARANTEE THAT WE WILL HAVE
MEDICINAL PRODUCTS OBVIOUSLY THE
ADULT USE MARKET IS. A IT IS
ASSUMED WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE LUCRATIVE AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE MEDICAL PRODUCTS ARE
AVAILABLE TO LEGITIMATE PATIENTS
AND PROTECTED LASTLY I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT. THERE IS NO
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE WAY AND
A TYPE CANNABIS PLANT IS GROWN
AND AN M. TYPE THE SAME APPLIES
TO THE WAY I CANNABIS IS
MANUFACTURED THERE'S VIRTUALLY
NO DISTINCTION OR. NO
DISTINCTION IN FACT IN MANY
INSTANCES SO AGAIN WE THINK THE
AUTHOR AND ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT FEEL FREE TOOK
HIM UP TO THE MIKE FROM A
MANIPULATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. MACROGLOSSUM BAFFLE FLOW
KANA AND CAL FOR HIM IS THE
RELIANCE Y. TO ECHO THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS AND JUST REITERATE THAT
THIS.
CURRENTLY UNDER THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THIS SUPPLY CHAIN
THEIR OPERABILITY IS ALLOWED
UNTIL JULY ONE TWENTY.
AT EIGHTEEN AS WE'VE DISPELLED
LOT OF THE CONTINUING TO TWENTY
NINETEEN SOME STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL.
HI GOOD MORNING CAN MAKE ON
BEHALF OF WE DROP CANNABIS
DELIVERY AND THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HOW LEARN THE CAST ON BEHALF OF
ALL GOOD LOC HIGHWAY INVESTMENTS
AND CAL CAN SOLUTIONS ALL
OPERATORS IN THE CANNABIS HAS
SPACE IN IN SUPPORT?
GOOD MORNING AARON OR WHAT ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION AND
FROM SUPPORT.
MARIN PANETTA WITHIN A CANONIST
BUSINESS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
RETURN MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS
REPRESENTING SO NEVA AND EASE
SOLUTIONS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY CARDALE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A THERAPEUTIC
ALTERNATIVE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE
OF THE MAJOR PROBLEMS THAT WERE
HAVING AT OUR RETAIL STORE FRONT
DISPENSARY HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AS THE ADULT USE MARKET GROWS
AND WE'RE REALLY HAVING A
PROBLEM AND NOT HAVING ENOUGH
THE PRODUCTS IN THAT AREA THANK
YOU.
DEAL DURING YOUR CALIFORNIA
NORMAL STRONG SUPPORT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL.
PAUL HAS VERY MINUTE SENIOR
COUNTY ACTIVISTS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOT ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE COMING ON MY
PHONE. CARILLO GET AND I FORGOT
TO SAY MENTION A HUNDRED AND
FIVE KIDS ON THIS LIST IN UNITED
STATES HAVE DIED BECAUSE OF
THIS.
INJURED INDUSTRY.
DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND.
WE ARE GETTING TIRED OF OUR
CHILDREN DYING.
SOME AS YOUNG IS TWO YEARS OLD
TWO MONTHS.
SIXTEEN MONTHS.
AND TEENAGERS.
DRIVING.
THIS IS NOT TO STOP.
STOP THE LIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEN NONE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AT AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NOT YET A MOTION.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND I'M ALL EXCEPT.
A DOCTOR QUIRK SO.
COMMENTS AS HIS CLOTHES A
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
LOW. LOW AYE BRO. BRO I
ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I
GEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MULLIN. TING.
THANKS EVERYONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX FORTY ONE.
BY DOCTOR WOULD.
DOCTOR WITH THIS DOES ENJOYING
AYE AYE SUPPORT SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES ON AYE WITH A MEN'S. OF
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHATEVER OUR READY AFTER THREE
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THREE MINUTES IN OPPOSITION.
SHOULD I JUST ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MOVE ON. THERE'S BEEN
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AS AND A
SECOND ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE IS TRYING TO.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS JASON RIGHT UP
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION.
GIVING PRODUCERS ACCESS TO
TEMPORARY LICENSE EVENTS BUILDS
THE AFFINITY BETWEEN THE
PRODUCER AND THE CONSUMER THAT'S
GONNA HELP.
THE REGULATED SUPPLY CHAIN BE
SUCCESSFUL MASSIVE THIS IS ABOUT
IT'S BROWN. DEREGULATE SUPPLY
CHAIN VERSES THE THE BLACK
MARKET.
AND PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THAT FOR PRODUCERS WHO WERE.
BECOMING LICENSED IS IS
ESSENTIAL TO MAKING THIS
TRANSITION POSSIBLE WITH ME IS
CAN BY CARLYLE ON BEHALF OF.
THEIR VEHICLE TURNED OF TO.
PROVIDE TESTIMONY SUPPORT.
GOOD DAY KIMBERLY CARD I'LL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
THERAPEUTIC ALTERNATIVE RETAIL
STOREFRONT DISPENSARY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS.
THIS SPELL SUPPORTS OUR ENTIRE
INDUSTRY TRANSITIONING THAT
SUPPORTS CULTIVATORS AND
MANUFACTURES GIVING THEM ACCESS
DIRECTLY TO THE CONSUMERS.
AND ORDER TO BUILD THEIR BRANDS
AND INCREASE THE REVENUE STREAM
AT THIS TIME OUR INDUSTRY IS
HAVING A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
TRANSITIONING THERE'S A NUMBER
OF BARRIERS AND ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO REDUCE THOSE BARRIERS
WOULD BE GREATLY APPRECIATED.
THIS BILL ALSO SUPPORTS
DISTRIBUTORS IN LABORATORIES. AS
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR QUALITY
CONTROL AND TRANSPORTATION.
AND IT'S A RETAIL MYSELF FOR
OVER TEN YEARS NOW THIS BILL
SUPPORTS RETAIL FACILITIES EVEN
THOUGH. ON THE OUTSIDE IT MAY
LOOK LIKE THIS BILL WOULD BE
COMPETING WITH US.
ACTUALLY WHEN MANUFACTURERS IN
CULTIVATORS PRODUCERS ARE ABLE
TO MEET WITH CONSUMERS THEY'RE
ABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT
THE CONSUMERS HAVE. THEIR ABLE
TO BUILD BRAND RECOGNITION AND
TRUST
IN THEIR PRODUCTS WITH THE
CONSUMERS THE CONSUMERS THEN
AFTER THE EVENT WILL COME TO
DISPENSARIES AND ASK FOR THOSE
PRODUCTS.
IN RETURN AYE WILL REACH OUT TO
MANUFACTURERS AND CULTIVATORS TO
CARRY THEIR PRODUCTS
AND INCREASE THE SALES FOR
PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS WILL BRING ADDED TAX
REVENUE AND INTRANSIGENT A
REGULATED MARKET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO ACTUALLY
IT WAS REMISS THIS AND I AM
ABSOLUTELY EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
SOME RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS.
IN THIS AT WHICH ACTUALLY LIMIT
THE SCOPE OF THESE.
THESE ACTIVITIES TO FOUR PER
YEAR PER LICENSEE
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE CLARIFICATION OF
RECOGNITION OF THE COMMITTEE
MINUTES AND THE OTHERS
ACCEPTANCE OF THAT. ANY
ADDITIONAL WHEN SUSPICIONS BEGIN
SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME
WITH MY FROM NAY MANIPULATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO MAXWELL'S
BAFFLING COLIN SUPPORT.
AB JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND
CALCRAFT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MAKING THE BOND AFTER WE GOT
CANNABIS DELIVERY IN SPORT.
PAUL SMITH AGAIN WITH THE RURAL
COUNTIES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
REALLY APPRECIATES AMENDMENTS TO
PROTECT THE DISTRIBUTION SCHEME
THANK YOU CAN.
SUCH I DON'T OF COURSE ABOUT THE
URBAN CANCER CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
NICK CAST ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPANY CANNABIS TOWARDS WOMEN'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DEAL GOING OUT CALIFORNIA NORMAL
IN SUPPORT.
PAUL HAS VERY MINUSCULE
ACTIVISTS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION FEEL FREE TO COME OUT
TO MY PHONE WILL ALLOW UP TO
THREE MINUTES.
TELLING IT LIKE IT AGAIN NO. BUT
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU GUYS GONNA SAY
YES ANYWAY AND DESTROY OUR.
THE HUMIDITY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
I SAW MARIN PANETTA WITH THE
NECK HAS BEEN THIS ALLIANCE I
HAVE FIRST OF ALL WE ARE
OPPOSITION CAME IN LATE SO WE
ASK THAT THAT. WE ASK FOR MISTER
WOODS BUILT TO MOVE FORWARD WE
DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
AYE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM. WE THINK THAT FOUR
EVENTS OPERATE YOUR PER LICENSEE
IT'S STILL A CONCERN FOR OUR
MEMBERS I. AND IE WE WE WANT TO
SEE IS A BILL MORE FOR AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
HI JESSE ROW WITH UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL BUT ARE
ALL LOOKING FOR THIS BILL TO
MOVE FORWARD SO WE CAN ENGAGE
THE AUTHORS OFFICE WITH THOSE
CONCERNS BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CAN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY
ONE VACANCY JUST BRIEFLY.
THAT TOWN OF PLEASANTON IN MY
DISTRICT HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST
FAIRGROUNDS IN THE STATE.
AND OF PLEASANTON DOESN'T WANT
ANY EXPANSION OR ANY ANYTHING
THEY STILL HAVE CONTROL UNDER
THIS BILL IF I AM CORRECT TO
HAVE. A DIRECT THAT. THAT CAN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME CIGNA DOCTOR WOULD DO
YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S RD BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW LOW AYE BRO.
BRO I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MULLIN. TING.
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WOULD
BELIEVE THAT WILL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY SYMBOL MEMBER
LACKEY.
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY THIS
ALSO DOES ENJOY AN I I SUPPORT
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHEN
EVERYBODY.
WELL GOOD LUCK. THIS AFTERNOON
YOU'D PROBABLY MORNING.
SO GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN WHICH
RESTORES THE REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT FRAMEWORK ORIGINALLY
SET FORTH.
IN THE MEDICAL CANNABIS
REGULATION TO SAFETY ACT UNDER
WHICH
CITIES A PERMIT CANNABIS
BUSINESSES ASSUME THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL. LOCAL
REGULATORY ACTIVITIES RELATING
TO THOSE BUSINESSES INCLUDING
THOSE NORMALLY PERFORMED BY THE
COUNTY.
DURING THE CONSOLIDATION OF MC
ARE SAY. WITH THE ADULT USE
MARIJUANA ACT INTO THEM
MEDICINAL AND A DON'T USE
CANNABIS.
REGULATION SAFETY ACT
THE PROVISION ADDRESSING LOCAL
REGULATORY RESPONSIBILITIES WAS
REVISED TO GET THE CITY'S
AUTHORITY TO ADMINISTER ONLY
SPECIAL RULES FOR THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
AND OKAY WELL I HAVE WITH ME.
PAUL SMITH WITH THE RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA TO
SPEAK IN NEED FOR THE BUCK.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PULSE WITH WITH
RC RC AS WE ARE IN SUPPORT AND
CO SPONSORING THIS WITH OUR
MUNICIPAL BROTHER WE THINK THIS
CLARIFIES.
SOME CHANGES THAT WERE MADE
LAST YEAR IN TERMS OF WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT.
AT THE MUNICIPAL LEVEL IN OUR
REGULATORY RESPONSIBILITIES AND
WOULD APPRECIATE OF THE SPORT OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIR JOINT OR SOME
BEHALF THE URBAN COUNTIES A
CALIFORNIA PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES WHO ARE ALSO A CO
SPONSOR. IS A PROVIDE AND YOU
CLARIFICATION FOR ESPECIALLY FOR
THE URBAN COUNTIES WHO DO
PROVIDE A LOT OF THE ENFORCEMENT
FOR THE CITY SO. URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN
DONE ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO HAVE THE
MICROPHONE CARILLO GET AND THE
COUNTIES DO DESERVE TO HAVE THE
RESPECT DUE FOR THE SUPERVISORS
TO VOTE.
SO I SAY NO TO THE BOIL PLEASE
RESPECTFULLY. GIVE THE COUNTIES
THE RIGHT TO. SAY YES OR NO TO
THIS AND NOT BE FORCED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE MISTER LACKEY DO
WISH TO CLOSE
I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
INDULGENCE AND ASK YOUR I
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS AS.
I JOIN AGAIN ENJOYING AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO ASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
LOW AYE AYE LOW AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FONG.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN MULLIN TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SIMILAR
LACKEY.
OKAY AND SEEING THE ABSENT OF
CREWMEMBERS WILL GO BACK TO A
FEW ITEMS
WELL LET'S GO AT FIRST TO. A
CONSENT COUNTER.
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET A MOTION
FOR A CONSENT HELD ITEMS.
THIS MOTION A SECOND.
WE CAN SENATE COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY NINE FOURTEEN
MOTIONS YOU PASSED A GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR MOTION IS D. PASS TO
PREPARATIONS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB THREE THREE THIRTY
ONE TWENTY SIX MOTIONS DO PASSED
TO JUDICIARY.
LOW AYE LOW AYE PEROT.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN. MULLIN.
TING.
GREAT WORK ALSO KEEP THAT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN
BY SEVEN MEMBER KALRA. WHO
PRESENTED EARLIER ABOUT WHEN WE
WERE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND?
BUT A MEMBER LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION AND A SECOND FOR ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN.
THEY MOVE THE BILL WITH WITH
IMMENSE IS THE MOTION VICE OF
AMERICA BLOOM. THIS IS AGAIN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
COMMITTEE SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOUD AYE AYE LOW
AYE BROWN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING.
BAKER NOW. BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN IPHONE.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN MULLIN TING.
AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA WHO ALSO PRESENTED
EARLIER. A WE NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
COOLEY SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
LOW AYE AYE LOW AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER NOW BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN NO TO.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE. GIPSON.
IT'S AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING HOLDEN.
IRWIN. MULLIN TING.
ONLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND THAT MEMBERS WERE JUST
WAITING NOW FOR AUTHORS TO
PRESENTS AND SO ARE SERGEANTS
ARE CALLING THROUGH. OF THE
REMAINING AUTHORS TO. PRESENT.
IT WE NOW SEE VERY TIMELY
FASHION. WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO PLEASE%
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE
READY YES THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE AND
AMENDMENTS IN COMMITTEE TO ADD
AND URGENCY CLASS TO THE BILL.
AS YOU KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STARTED ISSUING
LICENSES AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR. SEVERAL CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED REGARDING ADVERTISEMENTS.
NOT POSTING THE PROPER STATE
LICENSURE FOR INDIVIDUALS MAYBE
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY NINE
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
CLARIFYING THAT ALL
ADVERTISEMENTS FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESSES. BOTH OUT DURING
ONLINE MUST INCLUDE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THE LICENSE NUMBER
ON THE ADVERTISE.
THIS IS A LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT
LAW THAT NEEDS CLARITY AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAS CREATED A
SCENARIO WHERE. ADVERTISEMENT
PLATFORMS ARE UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THEY CAN
ADVERTISE FOR UNLICENSED
BUSINESSES.
I LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE'S SPECIFY IT SPECIFICALLY
IN SAN DIEGO IN SACRAMENTO HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS WITH THESE
ILLEGAL ADVERTISEMENTS IN
FEBRUARY. OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS HEALTH AND.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
CANNABIS REGULATION AN UPDATE ON
STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION DURING
THIS HEARING LEGISLATORS CITED
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF CANNABIS
ADVERTISE ADVERTISING. WHERE
LICENSE NUMBERS DID NOT APPEAR
TO BE DISPLAYED THE LEGISLATION
IS A SMALL STEP THIS LEGISLATION
OF THE SMALL STEP FORWARD MAKING
IT CLEAR THAT THE LICENSE NUMBER
ON ADVERTISEMENTS IT IS THE
LICENSE ISSUED BY THE STATE?
WITH THAT I A I HAVE YOUR
LINOCUTS CODE GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR THE UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. ON SABRINA CENTRIC
FANDRICH WITH THE BERKELEY
PATIENTS GROUP.
AND WITH THAT.
AND THAT OVER TO YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN UP TO THREE MINUTES OF OUR
WITNESSES COMMISSION IS PICKING
SUPPORT PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
WAS IT.
MARTIN AND I WHAT THE HECK CAN
HAS BEEN THIS ASSOCIATION WITH
THEIR CLIENT.
.
PAT YOU SEE BE YOUR ANTI.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE SUCCESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA REGULATORY FRAMEWORK.
IS THE ABILITY TO ELIMINATE
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
AS YOU KNOW MOST CONSUMERS USE
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS FOR
EVERYDAY NEEDS AND.
.
SEARCHING FOR A WHILE CANNABIS
WAS IS ONE OF SUCH NEAT SO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS ONLY
ARE UTILIZING LEGAL CAMPUS. OF
BUSINESSES WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS
ARE ONLY ADVERTISING OUT LEGAL
CAMPUS BUSINESSES THIS WILL
ALSO.
PROTECT THE CONSUMERS FROM.
NOT UTILIZING OF BUSINESSES
THAT ARE NOT TESTING THEIR
PRODUCTS AND A BUSINESSES THAT
ARE NOT PAYING THEIR TAXES.
ENSURING THAT THE BUSINESSES
AND DISPLAY OF THE STATE ISSUED
LICENSE NUMBER. WILL NOT ONLY.
CURB A LEGAL ACTIVITY BUT ALSO
PROTECT THE CONSUMERS.
HI MY NAME IS SABRINA FANDRICH.
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP OF
PPG IS THE OLDEST CONTINUOUSLY
OPERATING DISPENSARY THE COUNTRY
AND WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
DISPENSARIES TO GET AN ADULT USE
TEMPORARY LICENSE IN THE STATE.
NEW YEAR'S DAY MARKED A PIVOTAL
MILESTONE FOR US AND THAT STATES
ENTIRE INDUSTRY EXPECTATIONS
WERE REALLY HIGH. MANY OBSERVERS
WERE CONFIDENT THAT ADULT YOU
SALES WOULD BE A BOON FOR LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND ULTIMATELY WEED
OUT THE ILLICIT MARKET HOWEVER
FRUSTRATION QUICKLY OVERTAKE
EXCITEMENT HIGH TAX RATES THE
FINANCIAL COST OF COMPLIANCE.
INACTION BY MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UNLIMITED
ENFORCEMENT GAVE WAY TO THE EVER
PRESENT AND NEWLY EMPOWERED
UNREGULATED MARKET.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT THE GOAL
OF A REGULATED MARKET IS TO
BRING IN AS MANY OPERATORS AND A
COMPLIANCE AS POSSIBLE ENCOURAGE
CUSTOMERS TO PATRON LEGAL
DISPENSARIES WITH QUALITY LAB
TESTED CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
AND WE DON'T THE WAS IT MARKET
HOWEVER MANY FACTORS HAVE
EMERGED THAT ARE INHIBITING THE
SUCCESS OF OUR KNEES AND
INDUSTRY. AB TWENTY NINETY NINE
ADDRESSES ONE OF THESE FACTORS
AS IT RELATES TO TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS OR MORE SPECIFICALLY
ONLINE CANNABIS DIRECTORIES.
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER CONSUMER
FACING INDUSTRY TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS ARE CRITICAL TO OUR
MARKETING STRATEGY WE LIVE IN A
DIGITAL WORLD IN THE ABILITY TO
REACH OUR CONSUMER BASE RELIES
HEAVILY ON THE EXTENDED REACH
PROVIDED BY OUR ONLINE PRESENCE.
HOWEVER ADVERTISING UNLICENSED
OPERATORS ALONGSIDE LICENSE
OPERATORS WITH NO WAY FOR A
CONSUMER TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN THE TWO NOT ONLY
UNDERMINES THE NEW LEGAL MARKET
BUT ALSO POSES A. PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT.
THIS IS BECAUSE ONLY LICENSE
DISPENSARIES ARE REQUIRED TO
TAKE PAY TAXES AND SELL LAB
TESTED PRODUCTS.
THIS LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
EXTENDS FURTHER THAN SIMPLE
ONLINE A DIRECTORIES MANY OF
THESE CANNABIS TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS ARE ENGAGING IN
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY.
.
IN SOME CASES THERE IS NO WAY TO
EVEN KNOW WHAT DISPENSED WITH
THE PRODUCTS COMING FROM WHEN
ONE ORDERS ONLINE. HAVE ONE SUCH
EXAMPLE IS THERE A DELIVERY
PLATFORM EASE THIS BUSINESSES
ENGAGED IN NEGOTIATING WHOLESALE
PURCHASES RECEIVING ORDERS
VERIFYING ELIGIBILITY RECOUP
RECRUITING DRIVERS AND
ESSENTIALLY COORDINATING THE
SUPPLY CHAIN THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE LICENSE NUMBER TO BE
FOUND ANYWHERE ON THE WEBSITE.
SO THE QUESTION BECOMES WHO IS
LIABLE FOR THESE VIOLATIONS IT
THE CANNABIS TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM
IS EXAMS AND THE LICENSEE IS
ANONYMOUS THAT PUTS THE CONSUMER
AT RISK.
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY PROBLEM
THROUGH TWENTIETH CENTURY LANDS
ONLINE COMMERCE IS A STANDARD
BUSINESS MODEL IN TODAY'S WORLD
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE OVERSIGHT
TRANSPARENCY IN A CLEAR
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN. ONLINE
CANNABIS DIRECTORIES AND
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS WHOSE
APPLICATIONS EXTEND BEYOND A
PURELY INFORMATIONAL FUNCTION
AND INTO MY MARSHALL CANNABIS
ACTIVITY.
THEY THEY VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME AND
AFFILIATION FOR THE RECORD IF
YOU WISH TO USE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS AERONAUT ON BEHALF OF
THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION AND STOP SUPPORT
ABOUT THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS
REPRESENTING EASE SOLUTIONS.
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER SAID WE WORK THROUGH
LICENSED RETAILERS AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE IS LEGAL
AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN WORKING
ILLEGALLY IN THIS MARKET THANK
YOU.
JUST A GIRL WITH UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THINKING.
BRAND MAR NAM WE HAVE A SEEM
JEKYLL EVEN SUPPORT THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY WISH IT
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEN ON.
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO COME WITH A MICROPHONE.
CARILLO GET AND I'M SAYING NO TO
THIS BILL. BECAUSE THE
ADVERTISING WOULD BRING KIT SAN.
THANK AND POT IS OKAY AND IT'S
NOT.
BUT I GUESS SO CALLED ADULTS
WANT TO GO AND PRETEND LIKE IT
IS.
IT'LL SAVE LIVES.
THEY DON'T NEED TO ADVERTISE IN
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE GONNA DO POT
THERE'S GOING TO DO IT ANYWAY.
SO PLEASE KEEP IT OUT OF THE
HANDS OF OUR CHILDREN. IF YOU
GUYS HAVE A CONSCIENCE
PLEASE VOTE NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
AND AND A SECOND. ASSEMBLY WERE
RUBIO DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE
ABSOLUTELY. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
I I I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
THROUGH THIS BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
KNOW ALL THE REGULATIONS ARE
FOLLOWED AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
YOU GIVEN ME THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAKING I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. FIGURE VERY MUCH AS SOME
RUBIO AND YOU DID INDICATE THAT
YOU ARE ACCEPTING OF THE MEN'S
WITH RESPECT TO THE URGENCY ONLY
AND AGAIN THIS DOES ENJOYING AYE
RECOMMENDATION. AND WE JUST
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
THE A POLICY FOR CONSIDERATIONS
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS FOR
CONTINUE CONVERSATION.
ABSOLUTELY AND.
AS AS STATED I'M.
COMMITTED TO WORKING THROUGH
THIS I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AT
THE END OF THE DAY THAT
CONSUMERS ARE PROTECTED AND SO
WHATEVER IT IS THAT WHAT I HAVE
TO DO I WILL.
MORE THAN HAPPY.
WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE HERE OR WITH YOU
KNOW THE THE STAKEHOLDERS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF HIM OVER
THIS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE AN URGENCY COSTS
APPROPRIATIONS FLOW AYE LOW AYE
PEROT.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE
FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
DIGITAL MUCH SOME REVEALED WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
.
IT AS WE WAIT FOR ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS FOR PRESENTATION WILL
GROWTH TO.
FEELS AGAIN IN ORDER. TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT
SO.
.
KLAY SECTOR WHICH YOU LIST SINCE
THE START OF IN A FILE ORDER.
IN THAT IS WITH.
NUMBER A FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS ON CONSENT.
CONSENT ITEMS FOR CONSIDERATION
AB NINETEEN NINETY SIX AB TWENTY
NINE FOURTEEN A BEAT TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR. AB THREE ONE
TWO SIX
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
LEAVE THE ROLE OF IN FOR AFTER
MEMBERS ONE I'M GOING TO FILE
AND AND NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY BY
SOME RECORD.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN.
FILA ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
I WILL NOT VOTING TING.
TING AYE.
BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING.
WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE. GOT
MEMBERS SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO.
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
BIGGER NOT VOTING.
OKAY AND WILL USUALLY PAUSE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
PRESENCE OF AN AUTHOR WILL MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM. NUMBER ELEVEN.
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
BUT THEN THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY BY SUMMER GIPSON.
PLEASE TREAT FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHATEVER RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY.
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT TO
CANNABIS LICENSE CAN SHARE
COMMON SPACE. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING A AT LEAST SPACE TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO QUALIFY UNDER
THE LOS ANGELES ON CD SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAM THE LOS ANGELES
UM'S SOCIAL EQUITY POP PROGRAM
WAS ADOPTED TO ADDRESS THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT. ON INDIVIDUALS
AND COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
DISSOLUTE WAS WAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED BY THE
WAR ON DRUGS.
AS WELL AS CREATING OPPORTUNITY
FOR EQUITABLE ACCESS TO LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRIES AND TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS
REGULATES A DEFINITION OF
PROMISES PERMISSIVE.
IN THE WAY THAT ALLOWS ONLY ONE
LICENSE.
PER BUSINESS FLOOR PLAN.
THIS NEED TO BE CLARIFIED AS IT
CREATES A PROBLEM FOR SOCIAL
EQUITY LICENSING.
OF WHO MAY NEED TO USE THE SAME
ENTRANCE EXIT BATHROOMS OR
HALLWAY AS A GENERAL LICENSE.
THEY SHARE IN THE SAME SPACE.
THIS BILL WILL SEEK TO REVISE
THE DEFINITION TO ALLOW TO
LICENSE TO OCCUPY THE SAME
BUILDING OR AREA. AS WELL AS
CLARIFYING THE DEFINITION OF
STRUCTURE TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF
AVAILABLE LOCATIONS AND REDUCE
OVERHEAD COSTS FOR SMALL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES BUSINESSES.
THIS CHANGE IS NEEDED SO IT IS
IN ORDER TO ENSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THE LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AND EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES BUT THOSE WHO WERE
ONCE TARGETED. CRIMINALS.
FOR WHAT IS NOW A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES
ARE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION WHO WAS SELF
INTRODUCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTALITY FIRM
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF. OUR
MARIN BEEN WITH THE NECK HAS
BEEN ASSOCIATION JUST TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU KNOW WE PRIVATE
TESTIMONY HERE.
I WORK.
SO AB TO NINETY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY CLARIFIES A
DEFINITION OF PROMISES US OF THE
TO LICENSE SEES CAN OCCUPY THE
SAME BUILDING AND SHARE COMMON
USE AREAS. NOW TO BE CLEAR IT'S
ONLY A CLARIFICATION OF THAT
PROMISES DEFINITION AND IT'S
STILL PROHIBITS THAT ANY LICENSE
ACTIVITIES ACTUALLY TAKE PLACE.
AND AN EIGHTIES COMMON USE AREAS
AND REQUIRE THAT ANY LICENSE
ACTIVITY IS SEPARATED IN A
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT AREA OF
THE PROMISES.
SO THE BILL SIMPLY.
OUT ASKS THAT COMMON SPACES ARE
SHARED BY TWO LICENSEES AND ONE
BUILDING. UM THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES ENACTED A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK IN DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND PART OF
THAT REGULARLY FRAMEWORK IS A
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM.
THAT IS COMPRISED OF A THREE
TIER SYSTEM UP HERE WANTED TO.
HAS CRITERIA FOR SOCIAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS THAT INCLUDES BEING A
LOW INCOME RESIDING AT LEAST
FIVE YEARS IN A
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
AREA.
AND.
AS WELL HAVING PARK CANNABIS
CONVICTION
TIER THREE APPLICANTS CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAM BY PROVIDING TEN PERCENT
OF THEIR APPROACH OF THEIR
LEASED SPACE.
TIER ONE AND TIER TWO SOCIAL
EQUITY APPLICANTS
BUT THIS WOULD REQUIRE TO
LICENSE HOLDERS TO OCCUPY ONE
BUILDING NOW EACH LICENSE HOLDER
WOULD STILL HAVE A SEPARATE.
DESIGNATED PROMISES AND A STEP
SEPARATE AREA WITHIN THAT
BUILDING BUT WOULD BE ABLE TO
SHARE COMMON SPACES SUCH AS
HALLWAYS BATHROOMS THIS WOULD OF
COURSE REDUCE THE COST UP FOR
SOCIAL EQUITY LICENSE HOLDERS.
ARM IN BEING ABLE TO.
THEY FIND A COMPLIANT LOCATION
IN THE CITY OF LOS SANDERS IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE THERE ARE
ONLY SO MANY.
AVAILABLE LOCATIONS GIVEN THE
USE OF A SENSITIVE USE AND
ZONING RESTRICTIONS AND ON THE
CITY AND STATE LEVEL. OF THIS
THIS WOULD ALLOW SOCIAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS TO.
UTILIZE THESE ALREADY COMPLIANT
AND AVAILABLE LOCATIONS.
AND ALSO REDUCE THE COST FOR
SUCH RECORD APPLICANTS TO ENTER
INTO THE CANNABIS BUSINESS.
NOTABLY THAT CALIFORNIA PARTNER
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS ALREADY ISSUED
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS TO PROVIDE
FOR SHARED.
SPACE LICENSES IT'S AN*
LICENSE AND ALLOWS A.
CANNABIS MANUFACTURER LICENSEES
TO OCCUPY A THE SAME SPACE AND
SHARE QUIT MEANT.
AND IN FACT SHARE THE SAME
PROMISE THIS BILL DOESN'T ASK UP
BOOK THAT BOTH LICENSE HOLDER
SCARED THE SAME PREMISE JUST
THAT TO LICENSE HOLDERS CAN
OCCUPY THE SAME. BUILDING AND
SHARE THE COMMON AREAS WITHIN
THAT BUILDING.
THIS IS VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT FILLED SO
FREEDOM PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO.
WELL HELLO TO LOOK AT HER WE
HAVE THE CITY OF OAKLAND STRONG
SUPPORT I THINK WERE THE FIRST
CITY DOING A EQUITY ORDINANCE WE
THINK THE.
AUTHOR FOR ALL OF HIS WORK.
AFRICA ARGUES FOR FLOW CANA AND
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA CANVAS
DELIVERY ALLIANCE.
JASON BROUGHT UP WE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
JUST A GROWTH UNITED AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
NICK CAST TONIGHT WE HAVE CAL
CAN SOLUTIONS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE PART.
THAT I'M BALLABAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE CALIFORNIA
BLOCK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. EVEN
SPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FILL
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE.
CARE LIKE IT IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE THIS INDUSTRY HAS LIED
TO YOU ENOUGH.
IN NEEDS TO STOP THEIR NOT ONE
TO PAY THE STATE. THEY WANT TO
KEEP IT FOR THEIR OWN SELF.
SO PLEASE RESPECTFULLY SAY NO.
THANK YOU.
SAVE A LOT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RAN MARTIN
ON THE HEALTH OF CMG CLEAVER
PURSE OFF WE THINK THE GOAL OF
SOCIAL EQUITY IS A LAUDABLE
GOAL.
HUMBLE WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
GETTING TO THAT GOAL I'M AND
PUTTING AT RISK SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE. COLLECTIVELY
LEGISLATURE IN THE INDUSTRY HAVE
SOUGHT TO DO TO TRY AND KEEP
THIS THE SYSTEM IS TRANSPARENT
AND PRISTINE AS POSSIBLE TO
DELIVER TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM THAT. PEOPLE
DO NOT HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT ON
THE INTEGRITY OF
I'M ARE CONCERNED HAS LONG BEEN
IN THIS IS PARTLY BECAUSE WE
COME OUT OF THE CITY. WHERE THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS?
EDUCATED US VERY WELL ABOUT HOW
TO PROTECT OUR PROMISES.
SAN JOSE POLICE DEPARTMENT
INSISTS ON MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY SINGLE SQUARE INCH EXCEPT
THE RESTROOMS ARE COVERED.
AND AND PROTECTED AGAINST
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AS THEY SAY
DIVERSION AND OTHER ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE
NOT JUST IN THE PLACES WHERE THE
ACTIVITY AND WHETHER LICENSE
ACTIVITY IS ACTUALLY OCCURRING.
I'M WE'RE CONCERNED THAT ONCE
YOU CREATE A NEW ON CERTAIN
ELEMENT BY LIKE ADDING A SELF A
SECOND. OR MORE.
LICENSEE TO A SPACE YOU ARE
CREATING UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
WHETHER THAT SPACE CAN BE
PROTECTED AGAINST ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES WE THINK THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO GET AT THE SOCIAL
EQUITY GOALS WITHOUT PUTTING AT
RISK OF THE INTEGRITY OF THOSE
PROMISES AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU
NOT TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SEE NO WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON TO WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
RESPECTFULLY ASK LIVE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS DOES ENJOY IT AND I
RECOMMENDATION AND IT WILL NOW
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS FLOW AYE LOW AYE
BRO.
BROUGH NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
FONG.
GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRVINE I MULLIN TING.
TING AYE.
DID YOU VERY MUCH IS ADVOCATE
SYMBOL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX.
BY SUMMER COOPER.
PEACEFUL FEET PRESENT WHATEVER
RIGHT.
IT'S STILL MORNING BUT.
STILL MOURNING COMMIT MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST. OF THE
CANVAS BLACK MARKET IS
UNDERMINING LEGITIMATE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THAT GO TO GREAT
LENGTHS TO PLAY BY THE RULES.
IT'S UNDERGROUND MARKETS CUT OF
THE PROFITS OF LESSONS
BUSINESSES BY ADVERTISING THEIR
PRODUCTS. OUTSIDE OF THE
EXISTING LAW AND IN MANY CASES
SETTING UP FREQUENT GUEST ON
OPERATIONS.
CREATING A PUBLIC SAFETY
HAZARDS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX WILL
CLOSE A CIVIL PENALTY.
ILLEGITIMATE BUSINESSES
CHOOSE TO ADVERTISE THAT
DISPLAYING A VALID INACTIVE
LICENSE.
THE BILL ALSO CREATE A CRIMINAL
PENALTY ON THOSE WHO KNOWINGLY
RENT. LEASE OR MAKE AVAILABLE
SPACE FOR EXCESSIVE PROFIT TO
ILLEGITIMATE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
AB TWENTY SIXTY SIX WILL MAKE
AVAILABLE GRANT FUNDING TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES TRUE COURAGE
MORE LEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
I DON'T HAVE A CHAIRS
AMENDMENTS.
STEFFI ASKED.
THEY WOULD VERY MUCH IT IS MEANT
EMOTION AND A SECOND AYE SO SEE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF YOUR AB
JENKINS AND.
DID CANTATA.
HI DAVID CANTON WITH A
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION WITH
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AND.
AS YOU KNOW THE ILLICIT MARKET
CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE
GREATEST CHALLENGES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE LICENSEES FACE TODAY WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL GOES A
LONG WAY IN TRYING TO CAMP THAT
DOWN THANK YOU.
AB JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
FOR THE PRE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED.
ADDRESSING ILLICIT MARKET
ACTIVITY IS A KEY PRIORITY FOR
THE ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE AT
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TRACY
STEVENS AT THE SOLUTIONS WE ALSO
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RAN MARK ON THE HAVE THE SAME
JEKYLL EVEN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY DISH NO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT SEEN ON
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITION QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
RECRUITING MEMBERS HAS BEEN.
VICE YOUR PREP THANK WAS TERRACE
COOPER OUT THANKS FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FOR A CERTAINLY.
.
LOG IT'S IT'S.
INTENT BUT.
AS WELL.
WE DID A CIVIL ASSET FORFEITURE
BILL LAST SESSION RIGHT AND.
.
SINCE.
IT WAS ANDSCAPERS EVER GETTING
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TAKEN FROM
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS AND SINCE
THIS IS A CASH BUSINESS.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANY.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES TOWARDS
THAT CIVIL ASSET FORFEITURE
WITHOUT ANYBODY.
HAVING YOUR DUE PROCESS NO I
DON'T THINK SO THESE FOLKS THAT
CAME IN THEY HAD ALWAYS TO THE
BLACK MARKET BEEN GOING ON FOR
QUITE SOMETIME. AND WITH
CANNABIS BEING LEGAL.
JANUARY ONE OF THIS YEAR THE
FOLKS HAVE HAD TIME TO COME IN
AND BE LEGITIMATE AND THE FOLKS
THAT ARE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
RULED BUSINESSES. KNOW THE
BIGGEST THING IS A PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE OBVIOUSLY WE TEST THE
MARIJUANA OUT THERE FOR CITIZENS
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO AS A PUBLIC SAFETY NOT
REFERRING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT
A HEALTH ISSUE THROUGH AND MAKE
SURE THAT PRODUCT IS BEING SOLD.
IT'S BEEN TESTED IN IS A GOOD
PRODUCT THAT'S WHEN THE BIG
ISSUES WE HAVE NOW YOU'VE LATTE
PRODUCT OUT THERE. AND ALSO PART
OF WHAT'S GOING ON THE STATE'S
WAS ONE ENSURE THAT IF YOU'RE A
VENDOR IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU GET TO THE PROCESS AND
YOU'RE SELLING.
YEAH NOT CLEAR SALARIES IN THE
NOT SURE A LICENSE IF YOU'RE
LICENSE HUNDRED STATE EXACTLY.
EXACTLY UNDERSTAND SO OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CLAFLIN THAT
USER. I. SOMEONE EGGMAN.
MISS WHERE WHERE WHERE THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WILL PROBABLY
FROM WHERE THAT NUMBER COME
FROM.
TO REALLY HIT HIM HARD AND
OTHERS THE APPETITE NOT HERE
LEGISLATURE FOR CRIMINAL.
MORE CRIMINAL ISSUES OUR TIME
SO HIM HARDLY CIVIL PENALTIES TO
DETER THEM FROM BEING ENGAGED IN
THIS CELLS WITH THE BIG ISSUE
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT.
SO LIKE I SAID HE FOUND THE TIME
TO COME IN AND FOLKS STILL WANT
TO COME IN THERE'S STILL TIME TO
COME IN. SO THERE'S BEEN PLENTY
OF TIME WE'VE BEEN OUT FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS WITNESSES COMING
SO BUT IS THAT IS THAT TEN
THOUSAND IS OUT ANALOGOUS WITH
SOMETHING ELSE OR IS THAT. JUST.
WONDERS HIM HARD IT MADE HIM
REALIZE SAY DON'T DO THIS.
SO THE BIG ISSUE THAT IT COMES
DOWN TO IT PLOTTING OUR
CITIZENS.
FROM THAT PRODUCT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMEMORATIVE THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE AS SUMMER COOPER DO
WISH TO CLOSE OR STEFFI AFTER
I'VE OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SUMMER COOPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING THE NAMES THAT
YOU'VE ACCEPTED THIS DOES ENJOY
IT AYE RECOMMENDATION THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY WHICH PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY LOW AYE AYE LOW
AYE BRO.
BURN UP VOTING ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE. MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I SEE TO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND
I KNOW THESE WILL BE RELATIVELY
UP QUICK OF WILL GOING FILE
ORDER WHICH IS A FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX.
BY SOME OF OUR WALDRON A SUMMER
WALDRON THIS DOES ENJOY AND
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND SECOND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME ITS
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE.
I WILL BE BRIEF.
TODAY IMPRISONING AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX
A MEASURE THAT MAKES TECHNICAL
CORRECTIONS AND CONFORMING
CHANGES TO THE LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELOR
ACT.
AND.
AS WE NO. THEY HAVE OBTAINED
LICENSING AUTHORITY IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE.
AND.
THE THIS BILL WOULD ADD LPC SEE
SOON REMAINING CODE SECTIONS.
WHERE THEY WERE LEFT OUT?
WHERE LICENSED MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS
LONGSTANDING COMPARATIVE ALL
PROFESSIONS ARE INCLUDED AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS G. V.
AIRS I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS.
AND WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND AN INTEREST OF YOUR
TIME.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND HERE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. KENO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM KENNY MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME TINO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND. IN THIS AGAIN DOES
ENJOY AN AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION
COMMITTEE SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RUSSIANS DE PASSED TO JUDICIARY
LOW AYE LOW AYE PEROT. BRO I
ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE BY
BOTH OF YOU OUT WE WILL KEEP IT
WILL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. THIRTY SIXTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
AND WILL ALLOW UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND UP TO THREE MINUTES FOUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA WELCOME.
THE PRESENT.
AB THIRTY SIXTY ONE ACCORDING
TO A REPORT RECENTLY RELEASED BY
OTHER PLAYERS PROJECT.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
COUNTRY'S ILLICIT MASSAGE
BUSINESSES AND CONTAINS TWO OF
THE THREE MAIN CITIES IN THE
COUNTRY TO WHICH VICTIMS ARE
RECRUITED. TO COMBAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RINGS OPERATING AS
MASSAGE THERAPY BUSINESSES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ADOPTED A
VARIETY OF INDIVIDUAL ORDINANCES
ACROSS THE STATE. RANGING FROM
REGULATING MASSAGE BUSINESSES AS
SEXUALLY ORIENTED BUSINESSES TO
DOING NOTHING AT ALL AS IN
DESPITE THE STATE'S VOLUNTARY
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
MASSAGE PRACTITIONERS THIS
FRACTURED APPROACH TO REGULATING
THE MASSAGE THERAPY INDUSTRY HAS
FAILED TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AB THIRTY SIXTY ONE WILL ACQUIRE
A MASSAGE THERAPY ESTABLISHMENT
TO REGISTER WITH ITS COUNTY AS A
CONDITION OF OPERATION IN ORDER
TO BETTER COORDINATE. I'D FORCED
EFFORTS BY STATE COUNTIES AND
CITIES.
A THROUGH A FIRST OF ITS KIND
REGISTRY FOR MASSAGE THERAPY
ESTABLISHMENTS THIS BILL WILL DO
TWO THINGS ONE REDUCE THE STIGMA
FOR LEGITIMATE BUSINESS MASSAGE
BUSINESSES.
MANY OF WHICH OPERATED BY ARE
OPERATED BY VULNERABLE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
TO PROHIBIT UNLAWFUL
ESTABLISHMENTS FROM THE LOOTING
THE ORDINANCES OF ONE OF THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN FAVOR OF
A NEIGHBORING JURISDICTION.
I COMMITTED TO ENSURING THIS
REGISTRY S. ESTABLISHED UNDER
THIS BILL WILL COMPLEMENT
EXISTING EFFORTS THAT SOME
COUNTIES MAY HAVE ALREADY PUT IN
PLACE TO COMBAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WITH ME THIS MORNING
IS TONY SEE A CUT US.
THAT YEAH RIGHT CLOSE BECAUSE
THAT'S THE SECRET OF VALUE.
IT'S GREAT.
TO ME AND IN GENERAL OF HIS
GOVERNOR RELATIONS AHEAD OF
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF AMERICAN MASSAGE THERAPY
ASSOCIATION BUT YOU MISTER KING.
I HAD ALTERED OVER INFECTS
AGAINST HIM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO
THREE MINUTES.
MY NAME IS TONY PSYCHOSIS I'M
THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS CHAIR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN MASSAGE THERAPY
ASSOCIATION.
WERE SPONSORING A. B. THIRTY
SIXTY ONE ATTEMPT TO.
MAKE LIFE EASIER FOR MASSAGE
ESTABLISHMENTS AND MAKE IT
HARDER FOR COMMERCIAL SEX
BUSINESS TO OPEN AND OPERATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO DISH NO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT EITHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE GULF PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
TABLE.
AND.
WILL HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES IN
TOTALITY FOR.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION PEACEFUL
FREE TO PERCENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
OKAY.
IS IT I'M HERE. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I ALSO
VERY MUCH THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD MY NAME IS BERNADETTE
MURRAY. I AM A CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST
NUMBER TWO TWO TWO I'VE ALSO
BEEN PRACTICING IN WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA AS A SOLE PROPRIETOR.
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
I HAD BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND ALSO.
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
OFFICE ABOUT CONCERNS THAT I HAD
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL.
PRIMARILY THERE ARE THREE MAIN
ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
THAT I THINK NEED TO BE AMENDED.
THE FIRST COMPONENT OF THE BILL
HAS TO DO WITH THE.
THE WAY IT BECAUSE THERE IS A
CONFLICT BETWEEN ON CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN THE MASSAGE THERAPY
ACT AND HOW.
.
THERE ARE ACTUALLY THREE TYPES
OF SOLE PROPRIETORS THERE IS A
CERTIFIED MASSAGE PRACTITIONER
THERE'S A CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST IN THEN THERE ARE ALSO
NON CERTIFIED.
MASSAGE PROVIDERS UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT'S IT THE WAY THE LANGUAGE
IN THE PROPOSED BILL IS IS
CURRENTLY CRAFTED. IT ONLY
ADDRESSES CERTIFIED MASSAGE.
PRACTITIONERS AND IT
INADVERTENTLY DOES NOT ADDRESS
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST OR
NON CERTIFIED MASSAGE PROVIDERS
SO THE WAY THAT THE BILL IS
WRITTEN RIGHT NOW. I WOULD NOT
BE A MASSAGE ESTABLISHMENT OWNER
AND THEREFORE WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER NOR WOULD
MY COLLEAGUE. HUGE THAT SAY FOR
EXAMPLE JEANNIE VON WHO LIVES IN
YOLO COUNTY SHE'LL IS NOT
CERTIFIED AND SHE IS THE SOLE
PROVIDER AND SHE WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER UNDER THIS
BILL.
SO IT DOESN'T CAPTURE THE FULL
MARKET.
AS MOOD ALSO I'M AN WOODLAND WE
ALREADY HAVE. REAL VOCAL PULL
BUSINESS REGISTRATIONS FOR ALL
BUSINESSES IN WOODLAND NOT JUST
MASSAGE BUSINESSES. AND IN THAT
REVOKE WILL REGISTRATION
ORDINANCE
YEAH I AM WHAT IT HAS.
PROVISIONS
FOR.
DENYING REGISTRATIONS IT ALSO
HAS PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW FOR
APPEALS A PROPOSED RICK
REPLICATIONS OF REGISTRATIONS
AND BURIED CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THERE'S NO DUE PROCESS
PROVISION EXPLICITLY LAID OUT IN
THIS BILL RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THAT'S A MAJOR COMPONENT
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
THIRTY SECONDS LEFT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ALLOW MY
COLLEAGUES TO ALSO.
IT SPEAK AS WELL SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THIRTY SECONDS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME INVESTED IN THIS
DISCUSSION.
MY NAME IS LAUREN MCLAUCHLAN I'M
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST NUMBER TWO SEVEN ONE
EIGHT SEVEN I ALSO AM A
ROSEVILLE MASSAGE ESTABLISHMENT.
PERMIT HOLDER. I AM OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US
TO SPEAK I AM BJ PETS CMT NUMBER
FIVE FIVE TWO. AND IS THIS BILLS
WRITTEN TODAY I OPPOSE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
SENIOR AUDITION WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN.
.
WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL
THIS WAS A HUGE ISSUE THE
PROLIFERATION OF THESE MASSAGE
PARLORS AND JUST LAST WEEK WE
HAD A BIG BUST IN CAMERINO OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VERY INVOLVED
WITH.
TWO YEARS WHEN THE ISSUE FOR
CAME UP ARE YOU I DON'T SEE THEM
LISTED ARE YOU WORKING WITH THE
CITY'S AT ALL ON THIS BILL.
WEEK WE MUST BECAUSE OF THE
COMMITMENT THAT I HAVE TO TRY
AND MAKE THIS BILL OUT
COMPLIMENTS ME EXIST IN CITIES
LIKE THE ONES YOU MENTIONED
ACTUALLY TRYING. I THINK ONE OF
OUR CONCERNS IS THAT SOME
JURISDICTIONS SIMPLY PART TIME
AND SO. YOU GET A SHORT ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION IS YES.
AND IT HAD I'M A FOR OF ALMOST
ALL CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS THIS IS
THIS IS.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST COMPLAINTS WE
GET FROM OUR RESIDENTS.
THEY ARE PART.
COMMITMENT.
SHARE THAT EXPERIENCE IN THE
CITY COUNCIL AS WELL AS OUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SOMEONE
AND THAT'S ALSO CITIES CERTAIN
THE CITY COUNCIL.
IN THESE CAN BE A REAL PROBLEM
AND I A AND ALSO SOMEBODY WHO'S
WHO. ENJOYS MASSAGING AS NOT NOT
A LOT I KNOW THERE'S THERE'S
MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS OF OF WHAT
PEOPLE OFFER.
I'M SUPPORTING AT TO DAVID IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU STILL NEED TO DO
A LITTLE BIT OF WORK TO EXPAND
THAT UMBRELLA TO MAKE SURE
WELL ARE LEFT OUT. A AND AGAIN I
WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE WORKING
AND A CITY COUNTY CLERKS HERE IN
SUPPORT EITHER OR.
DID INTO IT COUNTY ORGANIZATION
OR THE LEAGUE CITIES SEEMS LIKE
ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO WHO WOULD BE
AT THE TABLE TO HELP CRAFT THIS
IN THE WAY THAT. I THINK WOULD
WOULD FURTHER ACHIEVE YOUR AIMS.
THAT'S OUR KITCHEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME SIMILAR
GOING IT DO WHICH DECLARE.
YES MISTER LARGEST WOULD SAY.
IN CLOSING THIS BILL IS VERY
MUCH OF A WORK IN PROGRESS
WORKING WITH THE BILL'S SPONSORS
WE WERE ABLE TO PUT THEM
TOGETHER TO HAVE THE COMMITTEES
REACTION TODAY. I WOULD CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ALL PARTIES
INVOLVEDTO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT
WE COME UP WITH IS A FRAMEWORK.
THEY GET STRENGTHENS THE THIS
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY WHICH IS A
FORM PART CALIFORNIA FACILITATES
THE DRESSING THAT THE BAD ACTORS
I THINK A CONCERT IN OFFICE.
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
EYEBROWS DID YOU VERY MUCH A
SIMILAR IN THAT YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT AND
STATEMENTS AND WORKING WITH THE
CONTINUED. A STAKEHOLDERS TO
STRENGTHEN THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND RECOGNIZING THAT
MANY OF US YOURSELF INCLUDED
HAVE SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION
OF THIS ISSUE. OUT THERE HAS
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND IS
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE SECOND
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
LOW EYEBROW. BROKE AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG
AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
GLOBALLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE IF ANY ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
ARE PRESENT. A SUMMER KILEY THIS
IS A FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
WHICH IS A ASSEMBLY WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY FOUR ZERO
NINE.
AND AGAIN WE'LL ALLOW UP TO
THREE MINUTES FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
AFTER THREE WITNESSES AYE THREE
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WELCOME AT HIM OF KILEY PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF ALL THE
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS CHERISH THE
FREEDOM TO EARN A LIVING.
TO WORK IN THE JOB OF OUR
CHOICE.
PERHAPS RECEIVES THE LEAST
PROTECTION.
OVERLY RESTRICTIVE OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE REQUIREMENTS
OUR SILENT JOB KILLER AND A
CAUSE OF POVERTY.
THIS IS A GROWING PROBLEM ACROSS
THE NATION.
MULTIPLE STUDIES FROM VARIOUS
SUBPARTS OF THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM.
HIGHLIGHTED THE PROBLEMS WITH
EXCESSIVE OFTEN ARBITRARY
GOVERNMENT ROAD BLOCKS TO A JOB
A PAYCHECK AND A CAREER WITH.
AND THIS PROBLEM IS WORSE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE
THE INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE LABEL
CALIFORNIA THE MOST BROADLY AN
ONEROUS LEE LICENSE STATE IN THE
NATION. AND THE WORST LICENSING
ENVIRONMENT FOR WORKERS IN A
LOWER INCOME OCCUPATIONS.
IN FACT ONE IN FIVE INDIVIDUALS
HERE MUST RECEIVE PERMISSION
FROM THE GOVERNMENT TO WORK THE
AVERAGE COST OF A LICENSES FOR
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX DOLLARS AN
INDIVIDUAL HAVE TO TAKE AN
AVERAGE OF TWO LICENSING. EXAMS
JUST A QUALIFIED TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
REYES SIMILAR CONCERNS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN STATING THE
STATE'S LICENSE LIGHTS ISN'T
PROCESS OFTEN BARS INTRIGUED
OCCUPATIONS AND IS NOT A
THOUGHTFUL EXAMINATION OF HOW
BEST TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
THE REPORT FOUND THAT CHANGES
WERE NEEDED TO INCREASE UPWARD
MOBILITY OF WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
FINALLY.
THE BROOKINGS INSTITUTE HAS
ADVOCATED FOR OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING REFORM AT THE LOCAL
STATE.
AND FEDERAL LEVEL ARGUING THAT
REDUCE REGULATIONS WILL CREATE
MORE JOBS IN THE LICENSE FIELDS
INCREASE CONSUMER ACCESS TO
GOODS AND SERVICES AND LEAD TO
LOWER PRICES ACROSS THE BOARD.
WELL WE DO RIGHTFULLY RELY ON
OCCUPATIONAL REGULATION FOR
PUBLIC PROTECTION.
THE BURDENS OF EXCESSIVE
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING ARE OFTEN
DISPROPORTIONATE OR ALTOGETHER
UNRELATED TO THE ACTUAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY RISKS
OF THE OCCUPATION.
I'LL GIVE YOU JUST THREE
EXAMPLES
BUT TODAY'S BILL WILL
IMMEDIATELY CORRECT.
FIRST.
EXISTING LAW IN CALIFORNIA
ALLOWS ABOARD AND OR AGENCY.
TO PROHIBIT INDIVIDUALS FROM
OBTAINING OR RENEWING AN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE
IF THEY BE FALL BEHIND ON THEIR
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS.
THIS POLICY NOT ONLY DENY
SOMEONE THE RIGHT TO EARN A
LIVING BUT IS OBVIOUSLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
LIMITING THE PERSON'S ABILITY TO
EARN INCOME AND CATCH UP ON THE
ISLANDS.
SEC.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS A BOARD
AND OR AGENCY TO BAR LICENSURE
FOR SOMEONE WHO IS FALLING
BEHIND ON THEIR TAX PAYMENTS.
ONCE AGAIN THIS IS A BLOW NOT
JUST TO THE RIGHT TO EARN A
LIVING BUT ALSO LIKELY. TO THE
STATE TREASURY.
THIRD.
CALIFORNIA'S ONEROUS LICENSING
LAWS MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE WITH A CRIMINAL RECORD.
TO FIND JOBS.
FORMER OFFENDERS ARE FREQUENTLY
DENIED PROFESSIONAL LICENSES AND
TYPICALLY HAVE NO ADVANCE
GUIDANCE ON WHETHER A CONVICTION
WOULD DISQUALIFY THEM FROM AN
OCCUPATION SO THEY JUMP THROUGH
ALL THE HOOPS ALL THE FEES
COURSES AND TRAINING. ONLY TO BE
DENIED.
AB TWO FOUR NINE WOULD ALLOW A
FORMER OFFENDER TO PETITION THE
BORDER AGENCY TO NOTIFY THEM
WHETHER THEY WILL QUALIFY FOR A
LICENSE.
AND THE SAD TRUTH COLLEAGUES IS
THAT THESE REGULATIONS OFTEN
FALL HARDEST ON THE LEAST
ADVANTAGED IN OUR SOCIETY.
PEOPLE WERE JUST TRYING TO EARN
AN HONEST LIVING BUT OFTEN DO
NOT HAVE THE TIME RESOURCES OR
ABILITY TO NAVIGATE COMPLEX IN
OFFICE OFTEN SENSELESS.
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL THE OCCUPATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY ACT HELPS TO CORRECT
THIS PROBLEM BY ELIMINATING
ARBITRARY BARS TO LICENSURE AND
ASSURING THAT RESTRICTIONS ON
THE RIGHT TO EARN A LIVING ARE
NO GREATER THAN NECESSARY. FOR
PUBLIC PROTECTION.
NOW I'M AWARE OF CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE ANALYSIS AND DIE I AM
WILLINGTON NARROW THE BILL
MOVING FORWARD. AYE AYES IT IS
HEADED TO AYE JUDICIARY NEXT TO
GET OUT TODAY IN A WAY THAT
ADDRESSES THE COMMITTEE AND THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BUILDING OF CALIFORNIANS GREATER
ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT TO AT
OCCUPATIONAL OPPORTUNITY WHEN
MAINTAINING THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC.
WITH ME TODAY IS HONEST ASIA
FROM THE PACIFIC LEGAL
FOUNDATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BECAUSE OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANA SEIZURE
BODEN ATTORNEY WITH PACIFIC
LEGAL FOUNDATION. AND I
REPRESENT WOULD BE WORKERS
ENTREPRENEURS WHEN THEY FACE A
RATIONAL BARRIERS TO EARNING A
LIVING IN THE STATE.
AB TWO FOUR NINE WOULD ADDRESS
TWO OF THOSE BEARS HAVE
GENERATED A LOT OF DISCUSSION IN
THE MOVEMENT FOR OCCUPATIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING REFORM.
THE ROOM AT THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM OF COURSE IS THAT
LICENSURE IS NO LONGER
RESTRICTED TWO OCCUPATIONS LIKE
LAWYERS AND DOCTORS. NOWADAYS
YOU NEED A LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA
TO UPHOLSTERED FURNITURE TO TRIM
TREES TO SHAMPOO HAIR OR TO
APPLY MAKEUP. AND OFTEN THE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS ARE
ONEROUS IT TAKES FIFTEEN HOURS
OF TRAINING IN TWO EXAMS TO GET
A LICENSE TO SIMPLY WASH
SOMEONE'S HAIR FOR MONEY.
THAT'S TEN TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
TRAINING NEEDED TO GET A LICENSE
TO BECOME AN EMT. AND IT'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT MOST PEOPLE DO
FOR THEMSELVES IN THEIR HOME ON
A REGULAR BASIS WITH NO TRAINING
AT ALL. AND THAT'S NOT A ONE OFF
IS ASSEMBLYMAN KILEY SAID ON
AVERAGE IT TAKES FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX DOLLARS EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN DAYS OF
TRAINING AND PASSING TWO EXAMS
JUST ENTER A LOW INCOME
OCCUPATION.
SO MANY OF THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS SAUDIS BEAR NO
RELATIONSHIP TO PUBLIC SAFETY
INSTEAD THEY SIMPLY PROTECT
ENTRENCHED BUSINESS INTERESTS
FROM COMPETITION.
IF WE WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE
ECONOMIC MOBILITY WE HAVE TO
OFFER THEM A PATH TO
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AB TWO FOUR
NINE WOULD PREVENT LICENSING
BODIES FROM DISQUALIFYING PEOPLE
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF UNPAID LOANS
TAXES ARE CRIMINAL HISTORIES.
WHICH HAVE NO BEARING ON
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE
QUALITY SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
AB TWO FOUR NINE IS A MODEST
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
GETTING RID OF SOME OF THE WORST
CONSEQUENCES OF LICENSURE RUN
AMOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT NOW LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WILL ALLOW UP TO
THREE MINUTES FOR WHEN ASSIST
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
.
I I GUESS TO TO SUMMARIZE THE
SOME OF THE POINTS RAISED BY
THE.
AUTHOR AND PROPONENTS REALLY DO
SOUND SINCE WHAT I THINK THEY'RE
IT THERE'S PROBABLY SOME COMMON
GROUND THERE ON THE IDEA OF.
LIMITING THE ABILITY FEEL TO BE
DENIED LICENSES BASED ON STUDENT
LOANS THINGS LIKE THAT BUT. THE
FACT IS THAT THIS BILL KIND OF
BLOWS OPEN THE PROCESS AND
REALLY JEOPARDIZES EVEN THE
EXISTENCE OF WHAT A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WORKER PROTECTION
REGULATIONS FROM. HEALTH AND
SAFETY TO A VARIETY OF OTHER
AREAS THAT ON WE SHOULD BE
REALLY CAREFUL WITH SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO
IS ALLOW. SAY SOMEONE WITHOUT
ANY EXPOSURE TO AN INDUSTRY TO
APPLY FOR A LICENSE GET DENIED
TOM TO GO THROUGH THE APPEAL
PROCESS ALSO GET THAT I'D. AND
THEN THEY CAN SUE IN COURT
AGREED TO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WHERE THEY CAN SUE.
TO ESSENTIALLY OVERTURN ANY
REGULATION AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THE NEW VERSION OF THE BILL
LIMITS IT TOO REGULATIONS WITHIN
THE JURISDICTION OF THE BOARD.
NOT.
TERRIBLY CLEAR WHAT THAT MEANS
BUT FOR EXAMPLE TO TAKE ON THE
TREE TRIMMING THAT WAS RAISED BY
THE ARM PROPONENTS. IT THE FOR
ONE THIS IS A VERY VERY
DANGEROUS OCCUPATION FACT WAS SO
DANGEROUS THAT KOLCHAK TO ENACT
A SPECIAL EMPHASIS PROGRAM A FEW
YEARS AGO BECAUSE THERE WERE.
TWELVE METALLIC HE'S IN A TWO
YEAR PERIOD OF SIX OF THOSE
OCCURRED IN A FOUR. FOUR OF THEM
OCCURRED IN A SIX WEEK PERIOD.
AND SO THERE ARE VERY GOOD
REASONS FOR WHY WE HAVE A. YOU
KNOW LONG BODY YOUR TREE
TRIMMING SAFETY REGULATIONS AND
SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
ALLOW SOMEONE TO SUE AND THEN
SAY. I THINK WE NEED TO OVERTURN
ALL THE STREET TRIMMING SAFETY
REGULATIONS AND SO THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
WHO LIKELY HAD LITTLE IF
ANYTHING TO DO WITH AN ACTING
THOSE REGULATIONS WOULD THEN BE
FORCED TO GO TO COURT? AND PROVE
BY A PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE
THAT ALL OF THOSE TREE TRIMMING
SAFETY REGULATIONS MEET. THEIR
DEFINITIONS OUTLINED IN IN THE
FIRST SECTION OF THIS BILL AND
WHERE THEY TO FAIL TO DO THAT
THE COURT IS EQUIRED TO ENJOY
ALL THOSE REGULATIONS AND SO. IT
CREATES THIS PROCESS WHERE AN
AGENCY THAT WASN'T RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE REGULATION COULD BE
FORCED TO DEFEND IT IN COURT.
AND IF THEY FAIL TO MEET THE
VERY HIGH BAR PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE THEN THE ENTIRE
REGULATION GETS AND JOIN THE
COURTS REQUIRED TO JUST THROW
THE WHOLE THING OUT. AND.
WORKER SAFETY WOULD PRETTY
CLEARLY WE BELIEVE BE
JEOPARDIZED BY THAT.
YOU'LL BE KIND OF AN
UNPRECEDENTED SYSTEM WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW HOW THAT WOULD WORK
WERE THE LICENSING BOARDS TO
FIND THEMSELVES IN COURT OVER
AND OVER TRYING TO. DEFEND
REGULATIONS THAT THEY WEREN'T
REALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROMULGATING SO ARE FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE IS OUR
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FORTY FIVE
SECONDS I.
FRED JONES ON BEHALF THE
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I WHO WERE NOT.
A UNIONIZED INDUSTRY.
BUT WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
MITCH MENTION THIS WE SEE THIS
IS DEREGULATION VIA LITIGATION.
AND THERE'S GOING TO BE A
PATCHWORK OF CONFLICTING
SUPERIOR COURT DECISIONS THAT
OUR STATE BOARD OF FARMING
BECAUSE INDOLOGY WHEN OUR
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
FOR THE MORE THAT THERE'S
RECENT RESEARCH THAT INDICATES
LICENSURE PROVIDES A ROAD
LESSONS.
EMPLOYMENT GAPS AMONG MINORITIES
AND WOMEN.
BECAUSE LICENSORS PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO EMPLOYERS ABOUT
THE BACKGROUND OF THOSE
LICENSEES
SO LICENSURE DOES HAVE A VALUE.
IN OUR CONNIE. AND JUSTIN
INTERESTING HISTORICAL SIDE NOTE
MENTIONING UNIONS EARLIER. AS
PRIVATE SECTOR UNIONIZATION HAS
DECREASED OVER THE LAST FORTY
YEARS.
GOVERNMENT HAS STEPPED INTO STEP
SET STANDARDS VIA LICENSORS
PROPORTIONALLY.
SO IT'S TRUE THAT UNDER TEN
PERCENT OF OUR ECONOMY WAS
LICENSE FIFTY YEARS AGO NOW IT'S
CLOSER TO A QUARTER.
BUT THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT
AND PROTECTING CONSUMERS AS
UNIONIZATION HAS DECREASED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME TO MY FROM. HIM
INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
MARKS BEGINNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH EUROPE
AFTER THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
POST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS VICE CHAIR
BRO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SCOTTY
UP THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FOR TODAY.
I DO AGREE THAT SOME LICENSING%
IS VERY BURDENSOME AND COULD BE
A VERY TO EMPLOYMENT. BUT YOUR
SPECIFIC MEASURE HERE TODAY
SEEMS TO BE VERY BROAD.
.
USUALLY IN SUNSET HEARINGS IS
WILL WE TAKE UP THESE ISSUES UP.
FOR.
ONE BOARD HAS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF RESERVES AND WE
QUESTION WHETHER THERE CHARGING
THEIR LICENSEES TOO MUCH.
OR OTHER BOARDS DON'T HAVE ANY
DESERVES.
WHO QUESTION WHAT THEY'RE GOING
THEIR MONEY I'D BE INTERESTED IN
YOUR THOUGHTS YOU SAID YOU'D BE
INTERESTED IN POSSIBLY NARROWING
HIS BILL? ABOUT TO GET A MEASURE
THAT WOULD PASSED THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. OF THE OPPOSITION MENTION
MAYBE A STUDENT LOAN. THE ANGLE
WHERE YOU WOULD GET YOUR LICENSE
SUSPENSION I JUST BE INTERESTED
IN HEARING YOUR THOUGHTS ON
MARRYING THE BILL TODAY.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT AND THERE ARE
AND.
EH DIFFERENT APPROACHES THAT ARE
OUT THERE FOR HOW TO GO ABOUT
NOW OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING
REFORM IN A IN A SENSIBLE WAY.
AND I THINK THERE'S A LEGITIMATE
DEBATE AS TO WHICH OF THOSE
APPROACHES IS VAST AND I ONE OF
THOSE IS IN FACT KINDA. ANYTHING
UP THE SUNSET AND SUNRISE REVIEW
PROCESS.
WE CHOSE TO GO WITH THAT THIS
PARTICULAR APPROACH FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS THAT THAT ON
STAGE YOU CAN GET INTO IT IN
MORE DETAIL.
BUT I YOU KNOW I I DO TAKE OUT
THE CONCERNS ABOUT. OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AYE I PERSONALLY THINK WE DO
NEED TO HAVE A MORE SYSTEMATIC.
REFORM PROCESS AND I'M NOT SURE
I AGREE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
SET OFF A A FEEDING FRENZY OF OF
LITIGATION I THINK WHAT WE'VE
SEEN STATES THAT HAVE DONE THIS
IS A JUST LEADS TO A GREATER
CARE BEING TAKEN. OUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE REGULATION ARE
PROPOSED IS ALIGNED WITH THE
PUBLIC PROTECTION PURPOSE ON BUT
I'D YOU KNOW A KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT WE MIGHT NOT REACH
AGREEMENT ON THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE THAT.
I AM WILLING TO LIMIT THE
BALLOT I'VE CONVEYED THIS TO THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE TO I KIND
OF THE THREE WHAT I'VE U. S.
PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS.
AND I YOU KNOW AYE REGRESSIVE
AYE BARRIERS TO AYE OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING.
THAT I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
REMARKS AND OTHERS AGAIN OUR
NUMBER ONE.
TO ELIMINATE THE. ABILITY TO
RESTRICT SOMEONE FROM GETTING
THEIR LICENSE JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE LATE WITH THE STUDENT
LOAN PAYMENT.
I NUMBER TWO I DOING THE SAME
THING.
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE IS.
LATE OR CALL BEHIND ON THEIR
TAXES.
AND NUMBER THREE I LIMITING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH SOMEONE
CAN BE DENIED OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE I JUST BECAUSE OF THE
PAST CRIMINAL CONVICTION I'M AS
WELL AS CREATING A PROCESS FOR
SOMEONE TO BE OUT HALF THE BOARD
BEFORE THEY GO THROUGH ALL THE
STEPS. YOU KNOW BY GO THROUGH
ALL THIS HE'S GONNA
AUTOMATICALLY DENY ME BASED UPON
THE CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS I THINK
THAT DOES A THREE PRETTY ARE
COMMON SENSEMEASURES THAT I
HOPE THE COMMITTEE CAN GET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SOMEONE
BAKER THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
KILEY FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND AND AND FOR POINTING OUT AS
THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
CONSTITUENTS IT'S NOT
CONSTITUENTS OR TRYING TO GET.
THE DOCTORS LICENSE OR THE
LOTTERY BUT THAT THE
CONSTITUENTS OR TRYING TO HAVE A
MOST ENTRY LEVEL GREAT. JOBS TO
BEGIN TO BUILD A CAREER THAT HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS
AND AND ALSO HOW LONG IT TAKES
THIS ISN'T JUST A FUNCTION OF
HAVING TO.
WHICH IS A BARRIER THAT WE
SHOULD ALSO BE WORKING ON I I
LIKE THE WAY THAT YOU ARE
INTERESTED IN HEARING THE BILL.
I HATE I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT WOULD BE
LEAVING OUT THE RIGHT ACTION.
TYPE I JUST MIGHT MAKE THE
OBSERVATIONS THIS THIS BODY HAS
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AND HAS
SUITS AGAINST BUSINESSES THAT
EVERY SINGLE STEP OF THE WAY AND
WHATEVER IT'S THE POSSIBILITY OF
MAYBE SAM.
THE STATE AND ADMITTEDLY I THINK
THE BILL IS A BIT BROAD IN THAT
RESPECT SUING THE STATE THAT'S
WHERE. WE HEAR A LOT OF
OPPOSITION THAT SUDDENLY WE
CAN'T ALLOW THE GOVERNMENT TO BE
HELD TO THE SAME LAWSUIT
STANDARD BUT. I AM I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW.
ON THIS THE.
OTHER POP YOU KNOW IF YOU WOULD
ALSO BE LOOKING AT ANCHOR JUST
DO THE SAME THERE'S THERE'S
DIFFERENT GRADATIONS OF HOW WE
MIGHT REGULATE.
INDUSTRIES AND AND AND AND
PROFESSIONS
WE HAD A CONSTRUCTIVE DISCUSSION
THIS MORNING OVER ONE BILL. AND
THAT WE HEARD FROM OUR GOOD
COLLEAGUE ON THE COMMITTEE FROM
SAN MATEO WHERE YOU HAVE
ATHLETIC TRAINERS IN THE PAST
THERE'S BEEN BILLS ABOUT TITLE
REGULATION.
PAT AND AND BEFORE SOMEONE CAN
PUT THEMSELVES OUT WITH A
CERTAIN TITLE THAT YOU'RE AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE MET CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS
THERE'S ABOARD THE KID. YOU KNOW
IDENTIFY THAT BUT. I ENCOURAGE
AS YOU'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
TO LOOK AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
GRADATIONS INSTEAD IT'S EITHER A
LICENSE OR IT'S NOTHING.
AND WE'VE GOT TO BE MUCH MORE
INNOVATIVE AND CREATIVE ABOUT
HOW WE ARE DOING THAT.
NOT JUST IN THE NAME OF WORK
PROTECTIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LOT OF THOSE IN A POT OF OTHER
PLACES IN STATE LAW.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO WATER
THERE'S DOWN NECESSARILY BUT FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
AND.
HAVE YOU PUT ANY THOUGHT INTO
HAVING GRADATIONS ALONG THOSE
LINES OR WOULD THAT BE PART OF
THE CONVERSATIONS BE WILLING TO
HAVE WITH CHAIR TO HELP YOUR
BILL GET OUT WHICH I HOPE WILL
DO TODAY. HAD THAT ABSOLUTE PART
OF THE CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING
TO HAVE AND I THINK THAT TIME
YOU KNOW THAT.
SORT OF LEAST RESTRICTIVE.
STANDARD IS KIND OF EMBODIED IN
THE LANGUAGE WE HAVE IN THE BELT
BUT THERE ARE OTHER KIND OF OUR
MODEL STATUTES THAT OTHER STATES
HAVE PURSUED THAT MAKE THAT
EXPLICIT. AND SORT OF I'LL LAY
OUT A HIERARCHY.
OF OF REGULATIONS IN TERMS OF
AYE YOU KNOW MOST LEAST
BURDENSOME I GUESS JUST BEING
LIKE THE FREE MARKET MOST
BURDENSOME BEING. OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE RIGHT BIMBOS PERSON SOME
AND I SAID REQUIRING THE SUNSET
AND SUNRISE REVIEW PROCESS TO
ASSURE AYE THAT THERE IS A GOOD
FIT BETWEEN THE BURDEN HOW
BURDENSOME THE REGULATION IS.
AND I AND WHAT THE PARTICULAR
PUBLIC PROTECTION
MRS SO THAT'S I ABSOLUTELY A
CONVERSATION THAT I'D LOVE TO I
HADN'T AS ISSUES FOR THEM AND I
THINK WE'VE SEEN BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IN MY. SHORT TIME HERE
EXACTLY WHEN SOMEBODY GETS THE
LICENSING REQUIREMENT IMPOSED
ITS I GOT THE LICENSE AND NOW I
DON'T WANT SOMEBODY ELSE TO. AND
I ALSO WANT THERE TO BE FEES
THAT BE CREATED VERY I WANT MORE
STEPS TO BE DONE. ITS OUR JOB
AND DUTY TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
LOOKING AT CONSUMER PROTECTION I
THINK IT'S A AND AND THE QUALITY
OF CARE AND INFORMATIONS ARE
GOING TO RECEIVE. BUT.
WE'VE GOT TO BE OPENING UP
PATHWAYS TO CAREERS WE'VE GOT TO
BE OPEN UP PATHWAYS TO CHIP GOOD
JOBS IN THIS IS A VERY THIS IS A
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA. I DON'T
THINK IT'S A A BADGE OF HONOR
WHEN WHEN CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE FEW STATES THAT HIS
LICENSING SOMETHING NECESSARILY
GOT TO REALLY LOOK AT THE
QUALITY OF IT BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
SO MUCH.
.
SO MANY BARRIERS TO THAT SO I
HOPE ENCOURAGE THAT WE MOVE THIS
FORWARD WITH THAT NARROW COMMON
SENSE MEASURES THE THREE THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED. AND IF YOU
WANT TO THROW IN THE MIX THE
POSSIBILITY OF GRADATIONS THAT
MIGHT HELP AS WELL SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS SORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER
FONG.
A AYE AYES ONE ECHO.
WHAT IS IN THEIR BAKER AND HAS
SAID THAT I PERSONALLY APPLY
THIS EFFORT CAN YOU CAN YOU AND
I GUESS SHED SOME LIGHT IN TERMS
OF?
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BEEN DENIED THEIR LICENSES DUE
TO OVER OR BURDENSOME THAT
LICENSING AND WE DO HAVE AN
EXTENT TO HAVE A RANGE? AYE SIR
WITH PERMISSION MISTER CHAIRMAN
I ABOUT MY ONCE AND FOR THAT
QUESTION. CERTAIN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
.
CURRENTLY IT SEEMS THAT THAT THE
TAXES THE ABILITY FOR BOARDS TO
DENY PEOPLE LICENSE BASED ON
UNPAID TAXES RIGHT NOW AT LA
ONLY PERMITS LICENSE AT PORTS TO
DO THAT FOR THE MOST EGREGIOUS
OFFENDERS BUT IT IS. THEY ARE
STILL ABLE THE BOARDS ARE STILL
ABLE TO ENACT REGULATIONS OF
THAT SORT IN THE FUTURE SO THIS
WOULD BE A PROPHYLACTIC MEASURE.
TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO OR
DISCOURAGE THEM FROM DOING THAT
IN THE FUTURE AND PROMOTE WE
KNOW WHEN I WHEN I REPRESENT
PEOPLE THESE LAWSUITS A LOT OF
TIMES.
THEY DON'T EVEN APPLY FOR A
LICENSE BECAUSE THEY JUST ASSUME
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BEAT
DENIED SO EVEN IF WE HAVE A LACK
OF INFORMATION REGARDING HOW
MANY PEOPLE ACTUALLY BEEN DENIED
WHAT WE DON'T SEE IS HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE NEVER EXCEPT FOR TO
EVEN APPLY BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT.
THEY WERE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
MEET THE CRITERIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK THAT
THIS IS IMPORTANT MAY AS US IN
THEIR BIGGEST IS THIS THIS IS
ABOUT CAREERS.
HE BUT A PROBABILITY AND WE WANT
TO GIVE PEOPLE THE PATH TO TO
REACH HIM WHATEVER TAD A LOT
WOULD WHATEVER CAREER GOALS THAT
THEY WANT. AND SO WE NEED TO
REEXAMINE I THINK.
.
AND THE BURDENS I THINK UP THE
STATE PLACES IN PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM LEAVING STARTING
THEIR CAREER IN THE FIRST PLACE
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME SOME MCCAULEY DO
WISH TO CLOSE.
I YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION AND FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
AGAIN I'M AYE AYE COMMITMENT AS
WE MOVE THIS SITE IF WE MOVES
FOR TO JUDICIARY WHICH I BELIEVE
MISTER OUT YOU AND STE REPORTER
ON SO THEY CAN. REYES HALIFAX IF
THINGS LOOK DIFFERENT STAUGHTON
LIKES TO DO THAT JUDICIARY ALL
THE TIME.
.
I IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO DEAL
WITH THREE THINGS NUMBER ONE
THIS IDEA THAT YOU CAN'T GET A
LICENSE IF YOU'LL ANDERSON LOAN
PAYMENTS I DON'T AND THAT'S FAIR
ON THAT MAKE SENSE. NUMBER TO
THE YOU CAN GET A LICENSE IF
YOU'RE AYE BEHIND YOUR TAXES
ITEM THAT'S GONNA MAKE SENSE THE
NUMBER THREE THAT WE REALLY
RESTRICT THE ABILITY OF FORMER
OFFENDERS TO BE ABLE TO GET A
LICENSE TO PURSUE A CAREER. I
WHICH I THINK IS ESSENTIAL TO
REHABILITATION SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE MR KILEY
I APPRECIATE OF THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT YOU PROVIDED IN PRESENTING
THIS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION AS
YOU MAY KNOW THIS COMMITTEE HAS
FOCUSED ON THAT CONSUMER
PROTECTION. A WITH A DO ALL DUE
RESPECT IT IS MY BELIEF ANALYSIS
THAT OF THIS GOES AGAINST OF
THAT DIRECTION OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND WITH RESPECT THEN TO OF. HOW
WE NEED TO REFORM OF MUCH OF THE
CRIMINAL HISTORY IN FACT?
SUMMARY A DAVID CHIU AND HIGHER
COSTS WEARING A BILL TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT THAT WE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE YOUR COAUTHOR SHIP ON A
WITH RESPECT TO ADDRESSING SOME
OF THESE ISSUES. ARE AND SO WITH
THAT ALL DUE RESPECT THIS DOES
HAVE BEEN NO RECOMMENDATION.
IS THERE A MOTION.
THERE IS A MOTION AND A BY VICE
CHAIR BROUGHT A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY WHEN BAKER. A COMMITTEE
SECRETARY WHICH PLEASE COLOR.
MOTION IS DEPOSITED UNIT
JUDICIARY ALLOW NO LOW NOW BRO.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
JOHN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU NOW CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NO FONG.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON NOW GRAYSON. GRAYSON NO
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
THERE WERE NO MULLIN.
MULLIN MOUNTING.
SCULLY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF IT
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAPIN YOU VERY
MUCH.
I SOME AMERICAN HIM.
WILL MOVE ON THEN TO SUMMER
CUNNINGHAM WHICH IS OUR FINAL
BILL PRESENTATION.
AND THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX.
THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING AMERICA PRESENT A.
B. TO SIX OH THREE.
THANK YOU CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
FIRE TRAINING INSTRUCTOR
CERTIFIED BY THE BUREAU OF
SECURITY AND INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES. TO RENEW FIRE PERMITS
BY SELF CERTIFYING.
THE THREE REQUIREMENTS FOR A
PERMIT ITS RANGE QUALIFICATION.
IT'S A WRITTEN EXAM IT'S A
FIREARM SAFETY COURSE THE LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES A RENEWAL OF
THIS PERMIT.
EVERY TWO YEARS AND WHILE THERE
HAVE NOT BEEN ANY REPORTED
ISSUES THE INDUSTRY BELIEVES
THAT MAKE SENSE TO REQUIRE THAT
RENEWAL PERMITS ARE CERTIFIED BY
A DIFFERENT QUALIFIED INSTRUCTOR
NOT A SELF CERTIFICATION
PROCESS.
I THINK IT'S A CON CENTURY
ENGINE LAW WITH ME TO MY RIGHT
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS DAVID
CHANDLER. HE'S WITH THE HE'S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE.
SECURITY AGENCIES GUARDS AND
ASSOCIATES.
KNOWN AS CAL SAGA.
WHO IS THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
THANK YOU.
AT THIS DOES ENJOY AN AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO DO SO.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS COMMITTEE.
AGAIN AS WAS CUNNINGHAM BIRD
INDICATED WE ARE LOOKING
FOR I'VE ALWAYS APPRECIATED
SPORTS IS A LOOPHOLE FIX.
IN THE A BMP CODE. AND A LITTLE
FOR ME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN
NINE ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TINO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
CAMINO AMBER'S AT THIS TIME.
SENIOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CAN YOU MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME SOME OF HER CUNNINGHAM YOU
WISH TO CALL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
LOW I KNOW I BROKE. BROUGH AYE
ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
BERMAN I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
AND LEAVE THEIR ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WORD NOW GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE UP ALL OF THE ITEMS
WHICH IS ITEMS OUT ONE. THROUGH
EIGHTEEN.
AND ANY AB SUMMERS WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE SHORTLY THEREAFTER AND.
WE WILL THEN GO ON TO ITEMS AND
CONSENT SOAK A COMMITTEE
SECRETARY WORKS.
LOOK AT CONSENT A COUNTER ITEMS.
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS AB
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AB TWENTY
NINE FOURTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR A. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY SECS BROWN.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CHIU. CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP MY PHONE.
FONG I HOLDEN.
I MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
OKAY SIXTEEN ZERO.
THOSE OUT.
.
FINALLY MEMBER TO AB TWENTY
TWENTY BY SOMEONE RECORD.
BUSH'S DO PASS AS AMENDED HER
PREPARATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I TO.
CHIU IPHONE.
FONG NOW.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I.
THE RISK THIRTEEN TO ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT.
NUMBER ONE TWO UP ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN BY SOME
AMERICANA.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AN EDITOR
PREPARATIONS BROWN.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I
CHU. CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DON'T.
FONG NOW GIPSON.
GIPSON NOW HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
BAKER CHANGE I.
THE BILL IS OF VOTERS OF
FORTUNATE TO THE BILL IS OUT WE
NOW MOVE ON TO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER WOULD.
MOTION DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM IPHONE.
PHONE UP WEARING HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
I DON'T IN NUMBER FIVE NINE FIVE
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN BY
SOMEONE LACKEY.
MOTIONS DE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
BROW. BROKE AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FONG. FONG AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
TING.
TING AYE.
SIXTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE BY SOME OF MY
RECORD.
MOTION YOU PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
TO.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
BAKER CHASE I.
FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FILE AND A NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
MOTION DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
JILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM IPHONE.
FONG OF VOTING GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I'M MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
NUMBER WHEN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
NINE BY SOME OF OUR RUBIO.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE AN URGENCY ACOSTA
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BRO ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DON'T.
FONG I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
SIXTEEN ZERO OF THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT.
MOTIONS YOU PASSED UP OPERATIONS
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM IPHONE.
FONG I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING. TING AYE.
IT SEEMS ZERO THAT VILLAGE OUT
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY BY SIMPLY MEMBER GIPSON.
MOTIONS DAY PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NOW TO.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG NO GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
THE VOTE IS STILL TWELVE TO
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT NOW MOVE
ONTO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BROWN NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW PHONE.
FONG NOW HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
BERMAN I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
TEN THE FIVE THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN WALTER.
MOTIONS DE PASSED TO JUDICIARY
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM IPHONE.
FONG I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
SIXTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE I'M A
NUMBER FOURTEEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR ZERO
NINE BY SUMMER KILEY THIS HAS A
NO RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE HOLD
WHILE.
MOTION IS JAPAN DE PASTOR
JUDICIARY ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOW BLOOM.
BLOOM NOW.
TING.
TING NOW.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN NOW.
THE BILL HAS. IT VOTE TOTAL IS
FIVE YES ELEVEN NO.
THE BILL FAILS.
STRESS FOR RECONSIDERATION.
GRANTED RECONSIDERATION ANY ONE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE
CONSIDERATION.
AT C. NOT. GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION.
NOT EVERYONE TO FOLLOW AND OVER
FIFTEEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX OH THREE BY THE
SUMMER CUNNINGHAM.
MOTIONS DE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
BLOOM.
WHEN I TING.
TING AYE.
SIXTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY ONE
BY SOME MEMBER GLORIA.
MOTIONS DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BIGGER NOT BIGGER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
SIX TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS UP.
AND. WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL.
I TWO MINUTES AND I SIERRA IT TO
OTHER MEMBERS AND LOCAL HAD AND
THAT ON A FEW MEMBERS HERE HERE
SHORTLY.
THAT CAN BE SURGERY WE HAVE A
FEW OF QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
A FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SIXTY ONE BY SUMMER GLORIA JUST
VERIFYING.
FOR.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
IS THAT.
MR CUNNINGHAM IS BAKER AND
POLITICALLY
OKAY PERJURED THANK YOU